I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everybody. Hi. We are very excited about today's episode. So, we have arrived in our rewatch to Threat Level Midnight. Mm-hmm. But we are not breaking that down this week. No. We're actually going to be breaking that down next week with writer B.J. Novak. Yes. So, if you do not already subscribe to Office Ladies, you might want
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们正在为您独家主持《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。大家好。嗨。我们对今天的节目感到非常兴奋。所以，我们的重温之旅已经来到了《午夜威胁级别》。嗯。但我们本周不打算剖析那一集。不。我们实际上将在下周与编剧B·J·诺瓦克一起剖析那一集。是的。所以，如果您还没有订阅“办公室女士”，您可能想要
to hit that subscribe button so you don't miss that one. Yes. And go over to Office Ladies on Instagram because we're going to be posting lots of photos and behind-the-scenes stuff that I think we need to talk about what's about to happen today. This week, we thought we might reach out to someone who loved this episode of The Office and is a huge Office fan. So much so, she even sampled the episode in one of her songs. Let's hear it. No, Billy. I haven't done that dance since my wife died. There's a whole crowd of people out there who need to learn how to do the scar. That's right. Billy Eilish is in the studio today to have a conversation with us about her love of The Office. I can't believe it. You guys
点击那个订阅按钮，这样您就不会错过那一集了。是的。去Instagram上的“办公室女士”主页看看，因为我们将发布大量照片和幕后花絮，我觉得我们需要聊聊今天即将发生的事情。本周，我们想联系一位热爱《办公室》这一集并且是《办公室》超级粉丝的人。不仅如此，她甚至还在自己的一首歌里采样了这一集。我们来听听。不，比利。自我妻子去世后，我就再没跳过那种舞了。外面有一大群人需要学习如何跳疤痕舞。没错。比利·艾利什今天来到录音室，与我们聊聊她对《办公室》的喜爱。我真不敢相信。你们
obviously know Billy Eilish from her amazing music career. At just 20 years old, she has won multiple Grammys. She's won an Academy Award. I mean, People's Choice Awards, Kids' Choice Awards, Billboard Music Awards, I Heart Music Awards. Name an award and she has probably won it. She also is a director. She directs her music videos. She has a book. She has a fragrance. Her new album is called Happier Than Ever. It is out now. You can find out about all this stuff on her website, BillyEilish.com, including her tour dates. And she's a super fan of The Office. Like super fan. Super super fan. And we are super fans of hers. So much so that we brought our kids in today. Yes. And here they are. They're in the studio.
显然知道比利·艾利什凭借她惊人的音乐生涯广为人知。年仅20岁，她就赢得了多项格莱美奖。她赢得过奥斯卡奖。我是说，人民选择奖、儿童选择奖、公告牌音乐奖、iHeart电台音乐奖。说出一个奖项，她可能都拿过。她还是一名导演。她自己执导音乐录影带。她有一本书。她有一款香水。她的新专辑名为《比以往任何时候都快乐》。现已发行。您可以在她的网站BillyEilish.com上找到关于这一切的信息，包括她的巡演日期。而且她是《办公室》的超级粉丝。绝对是超级粉丝。超级无敌粉丝。而我们是她的超级粉丝。以至于我们今天把孩子们带来了。是的。他们就在这儿。他们在录音室里。
You guys want to say hi? Hi. Hi. Hi. Hello. Hi. Oh, that's our kiddos. Yay. Are you guys excited to meet Billy? Yes. We are too. Yeah. For about a year now, Harper, you've been asking me what? Hi. When can we meet Billy? Yeah. Yeah. You said if Billy ever comes on the podcast, can I please come meet her? Well, we should probably scooch on out of here because we just got a text that she's moments away. Okay, let's take a break. And when we come back, Billy Eilish is going to be here. Woohoo. Yeah. Yeah. Billy Eilish is here today on Office Lady. Billy Eilish is here. I'm here. Hi, guys. Thank you for coming. Thank you for having me. In studio, right here, right now. We're really excited
你们想打个招呼吗？嗨。嗨。嗨。哈喽。嗨。哦，那是我们的孩子。耶。你们很高兴见到比利吗？是的。我们也是。耶。大约一年来，哈珀，你一直在问我什么？嗨。我们什么时候能见到比利？是的。是的。你说过如果比利来播客，我能去见见她吗？好吧，我们大概应该溜出去了，因为我们刚收到一条短信，说她马上就到了。好吧，我们休息一下。当我们回来时，比利·艾利什就会在这里。呜呼。耶。耶。比利·艾利什今天来到了办公室女士播客。比利·艾利什来了。我来了。嗨，伙计们。谢谢你们的到来。谢谢你们邀请我。在录音室里，就在此时此地。我们真的很兴奋
to talk all things Office with you. Oh, me too. Where should we start? Oh my gosh, wherever you would like. Okay, I'm going to kick us off. How did you discover the office? Was it with your family? Did you watch it with your folks? Well, okay, so I was a little kid when this was all starting. I didn't watch it as a kid because it's not a kid show, but that's super appropriate. No, it's not. But I would hear it all the time and I would hear people talk about it. And that's what she said was constantly being said. And I remember it was a really big part of my childhood was not understanding what that's what she said. And I would get very, very frustrated. And I would ask people, what does that mean? You
和你聊聊关于《办公室》的一切。哦，我也是。我们该从哪开始？哦天哪，你想从哪开始都行。好吧，我来开个头。你是怎么发现《办公室》的？是和家人一起吗？你和父母一起看的吗？好吧，所以这一切刚开始时我还个小孩子。我小时候没看它，因为它不是给小孩子看的，但这非常合适。不，它不是。但我总是听到它，我总是听到人们谈论它。“这也是她说的”这句话经常被提起。我记得我童年很大一部分时间是不理解“这也是她说的”是什么意思。我会感到非常非常沮丧。我会问别人，那是什么意思？你
would explain it to me. I don't ever remember hearing the first time about the office. Like it was just, I just knew about it forever. It was like the beginning. Yeah, I don't remember finding it. I don't remember hearing about it. I just, it was just part of life. It was like, you learn to speak and you don't, there's not like a day that you want to speak, you're just speaking. Yeah. And so that was kind of what the office and then I just didn't understand that's what she said. And I remember there was a specific moment. I must have been nine years old and I was sitting in my kitchen and my mom had a bunch of people over that I didn't really know. And somebody said something and somebody said that's what she said and
会向我解释。我不记得第一次听说《办公室》是什么时候了。就像是，我仿佛一辈子都知道它。就像是个开始。是的，我不记得我是怎么发现它的。我不记得我是怎么听说它的。我只是觉得它就是生活的一部分。就像你学会说话一样，你不会有个日子说你想学说话了，你自然而然就会说话了。是的。所以《办公室》差不多就是这样，然后我只是不懂“这也是她说的”是什么意思。我记得有一个特定的时刻。我当时一定九岁，正坐在厨房里，我妈妈家里来了很多我不太认识的人。有人说了句话，然后有人说了句“这也是她说的”，然后
everybody laughed. And I remember understanding it for the first time and being like, I didn't go. I figured it out. And then that was like, I was like, okay, got it. And then you're like, TWSS. Got it. Yes. And then I got like into that. And then I must have started watching it when I was probably 11. Do you remember the first episode you saw? I think I started it from the beginning. Really? I've seen it now. I believe it's about 30 times. 30 times? All the way through. You're a purist. Yeah. Do you only watch it in order? Do you skip around? I sometimes I skip a specific episode. Oh, I can't wait to hear that. It's honestly like Scott's Tots. I can't handle it. Oh, is that the cringiest for you? Can't do it.
大家都笑了。我记得我第一次听懂了，当时的感觉是，我没去。我弄明白了。然后就像是，我心想，好吧，懂了。然后你就变成了，TWSS（这也是她说的缩写）。懂了。是的。然后我就开始迷上那个了。然后我大概在11岁左右开始看它。你还记得你看到的第一集吗？我想我是从头开始看的。真的吗？我现在已经看过了。我想大约有30遍了。30遍？从头到尾。你是个纯粹主义者。是的。你只按顺序看吗？你会跳着看吗？我有时候会跳过某一集。哦，我迫不及待想听听这个了。老实说，就像《斯科特的 Tots》那一集。我承受不了。哦，那是你觉得最尴尬的一集吗？受不了。
It's so cringy. The second hand embarrassment. I just can't handle it. When we've been doing our rewatch, the one that hit me hard was Prince Family Paper. Yeah, that broke my heart. When they take down that sweet family paper company. And how bad he feels about it. I mean, I don't think I could watch that one again. I think I'd have to skip it. That was hard for me. Well, so for you guys, have you guys watched it all the way through fully or no? Okay, this might break your spirit. No, no, it's okay. I get it. We are rewatching it for the first time all the way through together. I mean, we'll catch an episode here or there like on a plane or maybe it'll come up on Comedy Central or you know what I mean over the years. But this
太尴尬了。那种二手尴尬。我简直受不了。当我们重温时，真正狠狠击中我的是《普林斯家族纸业公司》。是的，那让我心碎。当他们击垮那家温馨的家族纸业公司时。以及他对此感到多么糟糕。我的天，我觉得我没办法再看那一集了。我想我得跳过它。那一集对我很艰难。好吧，那么对你们来说，你们是从头到尾完整看过了，还是没有？好吧，这可能会打击到你们的积极性。不，不，没关系。我懂。我们是一起第一次从头到尾重温它。我的意思是，我们会偶尔看个一两集，比如在飞机上，或者可能会在喜剧中心频道看到，你知道我的意思，这些年来。但这
is the first time I have sat down and actually rewatched it. Yeah, watched it in order from beginning to end. Yeah, when it originally aired, we would get together as a cast and we would have cast screenings on Thursday night and watching each other's living rooms. And so I saw most of the episodes then. But I didn't watch every single episode. And so there's going to be a few that I haven't seen before. I'll be seeing them for the first time, which is crazy. It is crazy. Oh my God, you haven't seen all of them? Not all of them. I would say 98%. Yeah, we tried to watch every one when they aired. But it is very surreal because you're watching a version of you from, oh my God, what is it, 15 years ago? Yes. You know, I mean,
是我第一次坐下来真正重新观看它。是的，从头到尾按顺序观看。是的，当它最初播出时，我们会作为演员聚在一起，我们在周四晚上举行演员观影会，在彼此的客厅里观看。所以我当时看了大部分剧集。但我并没有看每一集。所以会有一些我以前没看过。我将是第一次看到它们，这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。哦天哪，你没有看过所有集？并非全部。我可以说98%吧。是的，它们播出时我们尽量每一集都看。但这是非常超现实的，因为你在看一个版本的你，来自，哦天哪，是多少年前，15年前？是的。你知道，我的意思是，
who was the kid that came up to you that was like, you look like an older version of Pam and you were like, I am an older version of Pam. Yeah. Oh no. He said, when was that? I was in a target and he was like, I'm sorry. Has anyone ever told you you look like like an older version of the person who played Pam on the office? And I said, I am an older version of the person who played Pam on the office. Oh my God. And he kind of didn't believe me. He wasn't sure. No, they don't. This happens. I mean, a lot of people discover the show through streaming and don't really have a concept of like how old it is, how far it goes back. I know. Because it hasn't really aged. I don't feel like it's aged much. It feels, it doesn't feel like an old show to me. There's some shows you
是哪个小孩走过来对你说，你看起来像年长版的帕姆，然后你说，我就是年长版的帕姆。是的。哦不。他说，那是什么时候？我在一个塔吉特百货，他说，对不起。有没有人跟你说过你长得像在《办公室》里扮演帕姆的那个人年纪大一点的版本？我说，我就是《办公室》里扮演帕姆那个人的年纪大一点的版本。哦天哪。然后他有点不相信我。他不太确定。不，他们不会。这种情况时有发生。我的意思是，很多人通过流媒体发现这部剧，并不太了解它有多老，它能追溯到多久以前。我知道。因为它真的没有老去。我觉得它没有变老多少。它感觉，对我来说它不像一部老剧。有些剧你
watch and it's like, this feels old. I mean, maybe like people because of the way the world is, it's aged in terms of humor. We say entertainment was a time stamp of when it was made. Yes. That's all I think it would be, but it hasn't aged. It's aged very well in my opinion. Yeah, it holds up. It does, right? It cracks me up. Billy, I have a question. This is from my daughter Harper. She would like to know if you could only watch one episode of The Office for the rest of your life, which one would it be? Oh my God, I wouldn't want to watch just one for the rest of my life. I've thought about this a lot though. Honestly, rewatching it, I just, I fall in love with different parts of it and different episodes every time. But my, my favorite kind of one of
看了会觉得，这感觉很老。我的意思是，也许人们因为世界现在的样子，它在幽默方面变老了。我们说娱乐是它被制作时的时代印记。是的。这就是我以为的全部，但它没有变老。在我看来它保鲜得很好。是的，它经得起考验。确实如此，对吧？它把我逗乐了。比利，我有个问题。这是我女儿哈珀提出的。她想知道如果你余生只能看《办公室》的一集，你会选哪一集？哦天哪，我可不想在余生里只看一集。不过我对此想了很多。说实话，重温它，我只是，我每次都会爱上它不同的部分和不同的剧集。但我的，我最喜欢的其中一集，
my favorites was my favorite for a long time was beach games. That one really gets me. Yeah, it just gets me. The scene where, actually the scene where Andy is in the sumo suit and then he's like so sad and it's just really hard. He's like, slow, like he's like, oh, it like hurts my stomach. Like the way he's looking at the water and he slowly just wants to touch the water and then he falls in and then you're there. You're like, I can't hear you. What? He's like, get help. Poor you. You know, that's really Ed. And all, even when he's floating far away, it was not a double. He just floated Ed out in that river. There was a man in a little like rowboat thing with a rope tied to Ed and he would like pull him out. Oh my God. I know. I loved that. I got to
我长久以来最喜欢的是《海滩游戏》。那一集真的很触动我。是的，就是很触动我。那个场景，实际上是安迪穿着相扑服然后他变得很难过，那真的很艰难。他说，慢，就像是，哦，它让我的胃很难受。就像他看着水的方式，他慢慢地只想碰一下水，然后他掉进去了，然后你在那。你会觉得，我听不见你说话。什么？他说，快来人。你真可怜。你知道，那真的是埃德。而且所有，甚至当他漂得很远的时候，那不是替身。埃德就是那样漂在那条河里的。有一个人坐在一艘小划艇似的东西里，绳子系在埃德身上，他会把他拉回来。哦天哪。我知道。我喜欢那个。我得
walk across the hot coals. Uh-huh. Was it actually hot coals? No. Did I make you believe it was? Yeah, you did. Tell me what it was because I think it's just as painful. It was. So it was like real lava rocks over. They dug a ditch in the ground and then they kind of filled it with some lights with gels to give it that glow. And then on top of that, they put like real lava rocks. And then along the side were real flames. Oh, so it was still really warm? It was sort of warm. Like they were very specific. Do not get near the edges of this fire walk thing, this coal walk. You saw your bare feet on little sharp little rocks. Thank you. I say it was like running over a bunch of Lego. Yeah. Eek. It had not feels. So it was painful, but not because it was hot,
走过炽热的煤炭。嗯哼。真的是炽热的煤炭吗？不是。是我让你相信它是真的吗？是的，你做到了。告诉我那是什么，因为我觉得它同样痛苦。是的。所以它其实是真正的熔岩石覆盖在上面。他们在地上挖了一条沟，然后他们用一些带凝胶的灯填满它来营造那种光芒。在那之上，他们放了真正的熔岩石。然后在两边是真正的火焰。哦，所以它摸起来还是真的很温热？有点温热。就像他们非常明确地要求：千万不要靠近这个火行道、这个煤行道的边缘。你赤脚踩在小小的尖锐的小石头上。谢谢。我可以说就像踩在了一堆乐高积木上。是的。哎哟。它没有感觉。所以它是痛苦的，但不是因为它热，
just because it was like digging into my feet. Yeah. And how many times did you do it? I think we did about three takes. Okay. Yeah. So not too bad. Pretty good. Yeah. And it was cold. Super cold. It was so cold. What was your guys' like, what was your favorite episode to shoot? Oh, I love this question because it's not what our favorite episode is. Right. Because filming it, that's what I mean. That's why it's different. That's what I mean. Yeah. Because that's another question of like, what is your favorite episode? What's your favorite episode you shot? You got a lot of big questions. I think I can actually sum it up into one answer. Okay. I'm going to say Dundee's because we were out of the office kind of for the first time and we were on a location
只是因为它像是在刺进我的脚里。是的。你拍了多少次？我想我们拍了大约三次。好的。是的。所以还不太糟糕。挺好的。是的。而且很冷。超级冷。天气太冷了。你们俩觉得，你们最喜欢拍摄哪一集？哦，我喜欢这个问题，因为这和我们最喜欢哪一集不一样。对。因为拍摄它，这就是我的意思。这就是为什么它不同。这就是我的意思。是的。因为那是另一个问题，比如，你最喜欢哪一集？你最喜欢拍哪一集？你有很多重大问题。我想我实际上可以把它总结为一个答案。好吧。我要说是《邓迪奖》那一集，因为那是我们某种意义上第一次离开办公室，我们在实景拍摄
and it had a slumber party feel to it. Yeah. Because we didn't really have trailers or anywhere to go and we were just hanging in that restaurant. Yeah. And oh, for like, you know, 12 hours. Yeah. Just in that one room. Yeah. And it was just fun and funny and nonstop. And I got to be drunk. Yeah. Or pretend to be. Steve kept improvising with rain on that keyboard, you know, like Dwight would do different things and we kept cracking up. Well, don't give rain Wilson a keyboard that makes sounds. No. No. Unless our burp noise. Yeah. No. That was just going crazy with it. To the point where I think they were like, Hey, rain, can you get through one? No, I totally remember because Steve, like my as Steve as Michael was making a speech and rain kept hitting the
而且它有一种睡衣派对的感觉。是的。因为我们真的没有化妆车或者任何可以去的地方，我们就只是在那家餐厅里闲逛。是的。而且哦，待了大概，你知道，12个小时。是的。就待在那个房间里。是的。而且它既有趣又搞笑，一刻不停。而且我可以喝醉。是的。或者假装喝醉。史蒂夫一直在用雷恩的那个键盘进行即兴表演，你知道的，就像德怀特会做各种各样的动作，我们一直在捧腹大笑。好吧，千万别给雷恩·威尔逊一个会发声的键盘。不。不。除非是我们的打嗝声。 yeah。不。他简直快玩疯了。以至于我觉得他们都在说，嘿，雷恩，你能演完一整段吗？不，我完全记得，因为史蒂夫，就像我扮演的史蒂夫作为迈克尔在发表演讲，而雷恩一直在按那个
Oh, yeah. Exactly. You were like, okay, you have to stop. Yeah. So that's your favorite to film and maybe one of your favorite episodes. Yeah. And here's the crazy thing because, you know, there was a big debate on that episode because we thought it might be the last episode of the office that ever aired. Because what? Yeah. For that season, we only got picked up for six episodes. Yeah. And it wasn't looking great. And so we had this big. Can you believe that when you think about it now? It's weird now, but that was our life for the first two seasons. At the end of the six episodes, they had our names, you know, on paper that they had laminated and velcroed to our trailer doors. And I went and I unvelcroed my paper laminated name. I was like,
哦，对。没错。你们当时就说，好吧，你得停下来。 yeah。所以那是你最喜欢拍的一集，也许也是你最喜欢的剧集之一。 yeah。这里有个疯狂的事，因为，你知道的，那一集有个很大的争议，因为我们以为那可能是《办公室》播出的最后一集。因为什么？是的。对于那一季，我们只续签了六集。 yeah。而且情况看起来不太妙。所以我们有这个大。当你现在回想起来，你能相信吗？现在觉得很奇怪，但那是我们头两季的生活。在那六集结束时，他们把我们的名字，你知道的，写在纸上，塑封好，然后用魔术贴粘在我们的化妆车门上。我走过去，把我的塑封名字扯了下来。我心想，
well, that was fun. I'm going to take this one. Oh my God. Yeah. After the six episodes. Yeah. This was after, yeah, this was our season two pickup. Yeah. And we thought maybe Dundee's would be our farewell. And I remember standing in the parking lot with Greg Daniels and saying, do we think Jim and Pam should kiss outside of the Dundee's just in case there's no more episodes of the office? Like, should we, like, should we have it as an alt? Yeah. Yeah. And then if they cancel the show, you can put that scene in. And if they don't cancel the show, we'll save it. And Greg said, no, we're not going to give them the option. If they want to see you to kiss, they're going to have to pick up the show. We're not going to give them the footage. That's right. But hold
好吧，那挺有趣的。我要把这个拿走。哦天哪。是的。在六集之后。是的。这是在，是的，这是我们的第二季续签。是的。我们以为《邓迪奖》可能是我们的告别演出。我还记得和格雷格·丹尼尔斯一起站在停车场说，我们觉得吉姆和帕姆应该在《邓迪奖》外面接吻吗，以防没有更多的《办公室》剧集了？就像，我们应该，我们应该把它作为一个备选吗？是的。是的。然后如果他们取消这部剧，你就可以把那个场景放进去。如果他们没有取消这部剧，我们就把它留着。格雷格说，不，我们不会给他们这个选择。如果他们想看你们接吻，他们就必须续订这部剧。我们不会把这段素材给他们的。没错。但是等等
up. Pam does kiss Jim. She does kiss Jim. Okay. I think they don't kiss till casino night. Are you crazy? She would literally use. I know, but it was like, it was like a sloppy fall into you kiss. It wasn't like kiss. Okay. I say, I know, I know. John and I argued about this too. You say Jim and Pam's first kiss is casino night. Yes. Well, that's their first, like, intentional, together, you know, consensual kiss. Yeah. Yeah. Or their first, like, passionate, really, whatever. And yeah, I guess, I guess in Dundee's, it's more, you're drunk and you love him and he's your friend and you hug him. My mouth is falling onto his mouth. Okay. Well, you've been on, I mean, like, that's like, I don't know about this
帕姆确实亲了吉姆。她确实亲了吉姆。好吧。我觉得他们直到赌场之夜才接吻。你疯了吗？她literally用的。我知道，但那就像是，那就像是一个笨拙的跌倒式接吻。那不是那种接吻。好吧，我说，我知道，我知道。约翰和我对此也争论过。你说吉姆和帕姆的初吻是赌场之夜。是的。嗯，那是他们的第一次，比如，故意的、在一起的、你知道的，你情我愿的接吻。是的。是的。或者他们的第一次，比如，热烈的、真正的、随便什么。是的，我想，我想在《邓迪奖》里，那更像是，你喝醉了，你爱他，他是你的朋友，你拥抱了他。我的嘴倒在了他的嘴上。好吧，你一直在，我的意思是，就像，我不知道这一部分
part. Because I mean, it is getting weaker for me. No, but, you know, when we talked to John about it, John was like, from Jim's perspective, they kissed. He got a kiss from this girl that he's liked forever. Yeah. Well, wouldn't you, yeah, I would agree with Jim's perspective. Yeah. I know. I hear it all. I hear it all. What about you, and what's your favorite episode to shoot and or to? Oh, man, this is so hard. I loved filming the Christmas episodes. They were so huge. My character always lost her mind, you know what I mean? Every time. Just screaming and throwing ornaments and stomping. And I loved all of that. So filming Christmas was really fun. I loved the scene in Yankee Swap when we all sat in a circle and traded gifts. And I got that jazz poster,
因为我的意思是，对我来说这变得越来越站不住脚了。不，但是，你知道的，当我们和约翰谈到这件事时，约翰说，从吉姆的角度来看，他们接吻了。他得到了这个他一直喜欢的女孩的一个吻。是的。好吧，难道你不会，是的，我会同意吉姆的角度。是的。我知道。我听到了所有的说法。我听到了所有的说法。那你呢，你最喜欢拍哪一集和/或？哦天哪，这太难了。我喜欢拍摄圣诞特辑。它们场面太宏大了。我的角色总是情绪崩溃，你知道我的意思吗？每次都是。尖叫、扔装饰品、跺脚。我喜欢所有这些。所以拍摄圣诞特辑真的很有趣。我喜欢《洋基换礼》里我们所有人坐在一个圈里交换礼物的那个场景。我拿到了那个爵士海报，
babies playing jazz instruments. Some people like these. Such a good line. Oh my, and it hung by my desk for like years. Yeah. I have one at home. I do. But I feel weird putting it up because it is babies like with the playing instruments. Yeah. Okay. But what my favorite episode is, is changing all the time. Now that we're watching it. I feel the same. And I rewatched. Oh God, it was so funny with my daughter. I rewatched the deposition. My character is barely in it. Like really, I don't think I have a single line in it. Jan in that deposition. And then when they get Michael's journal, and his journal is so dorky, but it's like, I'm dorky when I journal. Oh, we know, Ange. Oh, it's really a journal. I love your journal. Okay. Listen, you do? I do.
宝宝们在演奏爵士乐器。有些人喜欢这些。真是句好台词。哦天哪，它挂在我的办公桌旁好几年了。是的。我家里有一个。我确实有。但我把它挂出来觉得怪怪的，因为那是宝宝们在演奏乐器。是的。好吧。但我最喜欢的剧集一直在变。现在我们正在重温它。我有同感。我重温了。天哪，和我女儿一起看太搞笑了。我重温了《听证会》。我的角色在里面几乎没什么戏份。就像真的，我觉得我在里面连一句台词都没有。简在那场听证会上。然后当他们拿到迈克尔的日记时，他的日记是那么傻气，但就像是，我写日记时也很傻气。哦，我们知道，安吉拉。哦，这真的是一本。我喜欢你的日记。好吧。听着，你喜欢？我喜欢。
Okay. You've made Angela so happy. I journal too, but she is such a dorky journal artist. Well, we brought in one of my journals that I wrote in my 20s. And I was interning on Conan. I was living in New York, and I literally wrote something like, you'll never believe what happened today, but I got a run. Stay tuned. I'll fill you in later. XOXO, Angela. Right? But that's like, who am I writing to? I'm such a dork. You're writing to yourself. I know. Your future self. Oh, it's so dorky. It's a big deal. It's cute. Do you journal, like, what do you journal? Is it just like free association? I journal on my phone because it's easier for me. Oh, yeah. I'm not a fast writer. And I just journal anything that I think,
好吧。你把安吉拉高兴坏了。我也写日记，但她写日记的风格太傻了。好吧，我们带来了我20多岁时写的一本日记。我当时在柯南秀实习。我住在纽约，我简直写下了类似这样的话，你绝对不会相信今天发生了什么，但我走运了。敬请期待。我稍后再告诉你详情。亲吻抱抱，安吉拉。对吧？但就像是，我在写给谁呢？我真是个书呆子。你是在写给自己。我知道。写给未来的自己。哦，太傻了。这可是个大事。很可爱。你写日记吗，比如，你都写些什么？就只是自由联想法吗？我在手机上写日记，因为对我来说更方便。哦，是的。我写字不快。我只是把我想到的任何事情都记录下来，
because I've noticed in my life that you get excited and you tend to lie to yourself about your life and your situation and how you feel about stuff, because you really want to feel something. Yeah. And then you think, well, if I just say that's how I feel, then that's how I feel. I've been journaling for a while, but this year I was specifically like, you know what, I feel like I've done a lot of lying to myself about how I'm really feeling. Because I'm worried people are going to find it or post it or tell somebody, because that's a big fear of having this kind of life. And so I just made a decision to just write down every thought with the comfort that no one's going to read it. No one's ever going to know. I'm not going to have to worry
因为我注意到在我的生活中，你一激动，往往就会对自己的生活、你的处境以及你对某些事情的感受说谎，因为你真的很想去感受某种东西。是的。然后你会想，好吧，如果我只是说那是我的感受，那么那就是我的感受。我写日记有一段时间了，但今年我特别觉得，你知道吗，我觉得我对自己的真实感受说了很多谎。因为我担心人们会发现它、把它发到网上或者告诉别人，因为拥有这种生活的一大恐惧就是这个。所以我做了一个决定，把每一个想法都写下来，带着没有人会阅读它的安慰。没有人会永远知道。我不用为此担心
about it. It's just for me. So I just write freely anything that I think, which is dangerous for sure. But it feels really good. It's a lot better. It makes me feel good. Yeah. I have those journals. I have those journals from my 20s especially, where I lay it all out and I do have a slight fear that like, yeah, I'm going to pass away and like my kids are going to find it. And these are not all the things that my kids need to know about me. So I have an agreement with Angela. They're in a special cabinet and I showed Angela where they were. Okay. And so if anything happens to me, it is Angela's job to go in and burn the journals and destroy them because they destroy them. They're for me. Oh my God, dude. But this is your legacy though. Like you're you. People want your
关于这个。这只是我自己的事。所以我只是随心所欲地写下我脑子里的任何东西，这当然很危险。但感觉真的很好。好多了。这让我感觉很好。是的。我有那些日记。我特别有二十多岁时的日记，我在里面把一切都写了下来，我确实有一点小小的恐惧，那就是，是的，我要是去世了，我的孩子们会发现它。而这些并不是我的孩子们需要了解我的所有事情。所以我跟安吉拉有个约定。它们在一个特殊的柜子里，我给安吉拉看了它们在哪里。好的。所以如果我出了什么事，安吉拉的工作就是进去把日记烧掉，毁掉它们，因为毁掉它们。它们是为我准备的。天哪，老兄。但这也是你的遗产啊。比如你是你。人们想要你的
words after you pass on, dude. Do I want people to love me? I don't know. It's mostly like that's for me. And I like to go back and reflect. I like to go back and be like, what was my mind at 27? Where was I? What did I care about? What was I interested in? What was I worried about? And you see patterns over time when you review your journals. I see habits, habits of thinking, habits of behavior. It's really fascinating. But it's so personal. I'm not sure. In order to give me the freedom to really write it down, I need to know that Angela is going to burn them if anything happens to me. I told her I will torch them. It's the best friend agreement. Jay doesn't come. Really sweet. So I'm glad you guys have that. You need a BFF who can torch.
在你去世之后的话，老兄。我想让人们爱我吗？我不知道。这主要是为了我自己。我喜欢回头反思。我喜欢回头想想，我27岁时在想什么？我在哪里？我关心什么？我对什么感兴趣？我担心什么？当你回顾日记时，你会发现随着时间的推移形成的模式。我看到了习惯，思维习惯，行为习惯。这真的很迷人。但这太私密了。我不确定。为了让我有真正写下来的自由，我需要知道如果我出了什么事，安吉拉会把它们烧掉。我告诉她我会把它们付之一炬。这是闺蜜之间的约定。杰伊没来。真的很甜。所以我很高兴你们俩有这个约定。你需要一个能烧毁日记的闺蜜。
I know the problems might are all digital. So that's an issue. Well, I exist forever. It does. And I I've started a few years ago. I know I'm like a dinosaur, but that that notes app on my phone. So I love to write comedy. I love to like study people. So I have a whole notes on my phone. Jenna, I don't even know if I've ever shared this with you of just observations of people, situations, things that I might find funny. I have a handwritten notebook of that. You do? Yeah, I wrote one down the other day. I said, in case I ever need to play characters, I can look at all these notes. Woman who reapplies her lipstick immediately after finishing a meal. That's a person. That's a full character. I have a question for both of you,
我知道我的问题可能都在于它们都是数字化的。所以这是一个问题。好吧，我将永远存在。确实如此。我几年前开始的。我知道我像个恐龙，但是手机上的那个便签应用。所以我喜欢写喜剧。我喜欢研究人。所以我手机上有一整篇关于人的便签，詹娜，我甚至不知道我是否曾与你分享过这些，关于对人、情况、我可能会觉得有趣的事情的观察。我有一本手写的笔记本记录这些。你有吗？是的，我前几天写了一个。我说，以防我以后需要扮演角色，我可以看看所有这些笔记。一个在吃完饭后立即重新涂口红的女人。这就是一个人。这是一个完整的角色。我有一个问题要问你们两个，
because I I know what some of this stuff is like. What did you hate doing or like the process of making by the end of the run? It was less fun to sit in the background of all the scenes. I think about that a lot when I'm watching because you guys really be doing that. I think you guys are in the back of a lot of shots. Everybody, like all of the one-offs, like the talking heads. And you don't even think when you're watching, honestly, I don't even think about it unless I religiously watch like the bloopers of all the stuff. And that's when I notice I'm like, oh my God, Leslie David Baker and Creed in the back of every single one. Yeah, I know. For nine years. For nine years. I sometimes lucked out because I was behind
因为我知道其中一些事情是什么样子的。到剧集结束时，你们讨厌做什么或者讨厌制作过程中的什么？坐在所有场景的背景里就没那么有趣了。当我观看的时候我经常会想到这一点，因为你们真的在那样做。我认为你们在很多镜头的背景里。每个人，就像所有只出现一次的角色，比如面对镜头的访谈。当你观看时你甚至都不会去想，老兄，说实话，我甚至都不会去想它，除非我狂热地观看所有东西的幕后花絮。那时我才注意到，我会想，哦天哪，莱斯利·大卫·贝克和克里德出现在每一个镜头的背景里。是的，我知道。持续了九年。持续了九年。我有时很幸运，因为我躲在
a partition. And so I could be like, come on, guys, you can't see Angela riding here. Come on, you can barely see me when I stand up. I know for me, the thing that really got old was the fake pregnant belly because you had a body suit with the belly. And it was itchy and heavy. And Jenna had it first. And she was really griping about it. And I was like, okay, all right, it can't be that bad. And then I had it. And I was like, are you kidding me with this thing? Like to go pee, forget it. It was under the pillow thing. Wow. So it's not just a belly. It's like a full piece. It's like a wet suit. But then a little pocket that a belly goes. So your legs and your arms are in that thing. Yeah, you step into it, right? And how about this? We haven't gotten there
一个隔板后面。所以我可以想，得了吧，伙计们，你们看不到安吉拉坐在这里。得了吧，当我站起来时你们几乎看不到我。我知道对我来说，真正让人厌烦的是那个假孕肚，因为你得穿一件带有肚子的连体衣。它又痒又重。詹娜先用的。她一直在抱怨这个。我想，好吧，好吧，它不可能那么糟糕。然后我也用了。我就想，你在跟我开玩笑吧？比如去上厕所，想都别想。它在那个枕头状的东西下面。哇。所以它不只是一个肚子。它就像是一整件衣服。它就像是一件潜水服。但是还有一个小口袋可以放肚子。所以你的腿和胳膊都在那个东西里。是的，你走进去，对吧？还有这个？我们还没说到那儿呢，
yet. But when Robert California has this big party, we all go in the swimming pool. And they had me swim with that fake belly. Guess what? It absorbs water. I was like, oh, my God, you didn't sink to the bottom with your tiny self. I know. I got a good core workout. Do you have a favorite season of the office? I do. You do. What is it? Okay, three, four, and also five, but three and four are like, unbelievable. Five is also incredible. Incredible. But three and four, like it's just like Jim and Pam get together around there. Things are good. We're like, Michael's not leaving yet. We're in a good zone, man. There's not conflict as much yet. There's not like the senator yet. There's not Robert California yet. There's not Joe. There's not Gabe yet. And it's still, it's still,
但是当罗伯特·加州举办这个盛大的派对时，我们都跳进了游泳池。他们让我挺着那个假肚子游泳。你猜怎么着？它会吸水。我说，哦，天哪，你竟然没有带着你那小小的身躯沉到水底。我知道。我得到了很好的核心锻炼。你们有《办公室》最喜欢的季吗？我有。你有吗？是什么？好吧，第三季、第四季，还有第五季，但是第三季和第四季简直是不可思议。第五季也是无与伦比的。无与伦比。但是第三季和第四季，就像是吉姆和帕姆大约在那个时候走到了一起。一切都很好。我们觉得，迈克尔还没离开呢。我们处于一个很好的状态，伙计。冲突还没那么多。还没有参议员。还没有罗伯特·加州。还没有乔。还没有加布。而且它仍然，它仍然，
it stays really good. But those just couple seasons are just like, yeah, happiness. Can I bring you into a controversy? Yeah, please. Do you think that it was okay that Jim bought his parents' house in Frametownie without telling Pam first? Where do you stand? Romantic or controlling? I don't love it. But also people in their relationships have their own what's okay and what's not. That's a great answer. Even though these are not real characters, they are in the show. And it's not, it's up to Pam whether it was okay or not. Not me. Exactly. And I think it made Pam's life, she felt so taken care of. And also what I liked was that at first you're like, you know, this without telling me and like,
它一直都非常好。但那几季简直就是，是的，幸福。我可以带你们讨论一个争议吗？好的，请说。你觉得吉姆在没有先告诉帕姆的情况下在雷姆敦买了父母的房子，这可以吗？你的立场是什么？浪漫还是控制欲强？我不太喜欢。但人们在他们的关系中也有他们自己觉得可以和不可以的标准。这真是一个伟大的回答。尽管这些不是真实的角色，但他们在剧里。而且这，这取决于帕姆觉得可以还是不可以。而不是我。没错。而且我认为这让帕姆的生活，让她觉得受到了很好的照顾。另外我喜欢的是，一开始你会觉得，你知道，你没告诉我这事，而且，
look at all these weird things going on. And you have this whole concern and everyone that's watching is like, yeah, what the hell is going on? And then it's this like very sweet touching moment of you being like, I love it. Like, look at this. Like, I don't even care about any of the anything, but you, you bought me this, you know, you bought me a house. That's amazing. So it's like, I think, I think you can see it from, from both sides. Like, I wouldn't want someone to do that in my life. But also it's like, it depends on the situation and the person and your life and the thing, you know, and I think also what came before it was Roy, who was so noncommittal, they were engaged for so long. And then you meet us. And then you meet Jim, who's like, all in.
看看所有这些奇怪的事情正在发生。你有这方面的顾虑，所有观看的人都在想，是的，到底发生什么事了？然后这是一个非常甜蜜感人的时刻，你说，我喜欢它。看这个。就像，我甚至不在乎任何其他事情，除了你，你给我买了这个，你知道，你给我买了一座房子。这太棒了。所以这就像，我认为，我认为你可以从双方的角度来看待它。就像，我不会希望有人在我的生活中这样做。但同时这也取决于情况、个人、你的生活和事情，你知道的，而且我认为它之前发生的事情是罗伊，他太优柔寡断了，他们订婚了那么久。然后你遇到了我们。然后你遇到了吉姆，他就像是，全力以赴。
Yeah. And how good that must have felt. So yeah, it's true, actually. And someone who didn't do anything for Pam ever. And then it's like, yeah, maybe it's so far the other direction that it could be too far, but it's so nothing like she's ever experienced that it's like really touching to do that, you know, which is sweet. It's interesting because when that episode came up, I said, and we've had these conversations before, what do you do when something has been written for your character that you don't agree with? Yeah, that you're, you're like, how do I get behind this? I don't know how to wrap my head around it. And Greg said something similar, which is that Jenna wouldn't like this, but Pam does. And very similarly, Jenna does not like
是的。那感觉一定有多好。所以是的，这确实是真的。而且是一个从不为帕姆做任何事的人。然后就觉得，是的，也许它朝着另一个方向发展得太远了，可能会有点过头，但这与她以前经历过的任何事情都太不相同了，所以这样做真的很感人，你知道，这很甜蜜。有趣的是，当那一集播出时我说过，我们以前也进行过这些对话，当你不同意为你角色编写的内容时，你会怎么做？是的，你会想，我该如何接受这个？我不知道该怎么接受它。格雷格说了类似的话，那就是詹娜不会喜欢这个，但帕姆喜欢。非常相似的是，詹娜不喜欢
being tickled, but Pam seemed to respond well to it. When Roy tickles her, she would always like come around, she liked being tickled. And I was like, but this one's really difficult for me because I have a physical, like visceral response to tickling that just causes sort of rage. Oh my God, dude, my mother is over there. Is this true? My mom will, I'm getting a thumbs up from your mom. Serious. I have to resist with all my might, hitting the person who tickles. Yes. Thank you. Tickling is a serious thing. My brother tickled me. We were in anthropology when I was a little kid and my brother started tickling me and I, I had an overreaction to make him feel bad. I was like, oh my God, stop. And I like swung my whole body and I, I bonked myself on the corner of a table
被挠痒痒，但帕姆似乎对此反应很好。当罗伊挠她痒痒时，她总是会顺从，她喜欢被挠痒痒。而我想说的是，但这一段对真的让我很难接受，因为我对挠痒痒有一种身体上的、本能的反应，这只会引发某种愤怒。哦，天哪，老兄，我妈妈就在那边。这是真的吗？我妈会，我得到了你妈妈的竖大拇指。真的。我必须拼尽全力去克制，不去打那个挠痒痒的人。是的。谢谢。挠痒痒是一件严肃的事。我哥哥挠我痒痒。当我是个小孩子的时候，我们在人类学博物馆，我哥哥开始挠我痒痒，我，我做出了过度的反应让他觉得不好受。我说，哦，天哪，停下。我像这样挥动着整个身体，然后我把头撞到了桌子角上，
and gave myself a black eye. Oh no. And I always blamed him because he was tickling me. Did he ever tickle you again? Yeah. Okay. But, but he was scared too because I'd be like, I'll give myself a black eye and I'll blame it on you. Yeah. Older brother gets the punishment. But no, I agree that I'd be furious if somebody bought a house and didn't ask me or tell me. Yeah. Be furious. Jenna wouldn't like that. Yeah. But then it's also like funny when you sell the house. I'm telling him absolutely bonkers. That happens. But it's like, you have a point, you're like, well, you bought it without telling me. So I thought I could sell it without telling you. Every time I hear that line, I'm like, unbelievable. I know. You bought the house
弄出了一个黑眼圈。哦，不。我总是怪他，因为他在挠我痒痒。他再也没有挠过你痒痒吗？是的。好吧。但是，但他也害怕，因为我会说，我会给自己弄个黑眼圈，然后怪到你头上。是的。哥哥受到了惩罚。但是不，我同意，如果有人买了一座房子却没有问我或告诉我，我会气疯的。是的。会气疯的。詹娜不会喜欢那样的。是的。但随后当你卖掉房子时也觉得很有趣。我告诉他绝对是疯了。这种事会发生。但这就好像，你说的有道理，你会想，好吧，你买它的时候没有告诉我。所以我以为我可以在不告诉你的情况下把它卖掉。每次我听到那句台词，我都觉得，难以置信。我知道。你买了房子
without telling me. So I'm like, sell it. I know. It's a weird book. It's a crazy relationship. Maybe she had been holding onto it a little bit. I don't know. Clearly. Clearly. I mean, every week I had to reconcile with a character that was very different from me. Like, oh, yeah, all of my reactions, everything. So I can really relate to that. I mean, there were plenty of times where I was like, okay, can we dial Angela back just a little? Like, can she not always just be the bitch? And I loved that note that Ken Quapas gave me. He was like, Angela, today, why don't you try being the suspicious bitch? And I was like, ooh, she's totally different than like the strict bitch suspicious bitch. Was there anything in Angela's character that you did like resonate with at
却没有告诉我。所以我只想说，卖掉它。我知道。这是一本奇怪的书。这是一段疯狂的关系。也许她一直有点放不下。我不知道。很显然。我是说，每周我都必须和一个与我非常不同的角色达成和解。比如，哦，是的，我所有的反应，所有的一切。所以我真的能感同身受。我是说，有很多次我都觉得，好吧，我们能稍微收敛一点安吉拉吗？比如，她能不能不总是那么刻薄？我非常喜欢肯·夸帕斯给我的那个意见。他说，安吉拉，今天，你为什么不试着做一个多疑的刻薄鬼呢？我就想，哦，她和那种严厉的刻薄鬼、多疑的刻薄鬼完全不同。安吉拉这个角色的身上有什么是你真正产生共鸣的吗？
all? I mean, I do love animals. I mean, I don't know. I haven't ever licked my cat. I did really do that, Billy. Yeah, I was gonna ask. I really licked it. I love that you did. I mean, they were like, it's just one take. We're just one take. We're going to be a little bit closer. And I was like, oh, and then I licked the cat. But I also like Angela. She's when she's in, she's very loyal, like, you know, like, I don't think she ever gave up on Dwight, even though they were such a weird on and off again, romance, but he was her soup snake. You know, it's true. So I guess those two things, but pretty much nothing else. If you're an office character, which one would you be? Good one. I've always really resonated with Michael's character, which is
我是说，我确实很喜欢动物。我是说，我不知道。我从来没有舔过我的猫。我真的那样做了，比利。是的，我要问的就是这个。我真的舔了。我喜欢你这么做。我是说，他们当时说，只有一个镜头。我们就拍一个镜头。我们会离得近一点。然后我就想，哦，接着我就舔了那只猫。但我也喜欢安吉拉。当她投入时，她非常忠诚，你知道的，就像，我不认为她曾经放弃过德怀特，尽管他们有着如此奇怪的断断续续的浪漫史，但他就是她的“汤面蛇”。你知道，这是真的。所以我想就这两点，但几乎没有别的了。如果你是《办公室》里的一个角色，你会是哪一个？好问题。我一直对迈克尔这个角色很有共鸣，这
maybe problematic. I just I've said that before to like my mom or like my parents and my brother and stuff. But it's really true. I see a lot of my character and not some stuff like more of just like, I can't even really explain it. There's just something that I really, really, really relate to about his character. One of my favorite favorite moments is when he can't help but shout. That's what she said, even if he's like, furious, like when when she when she is about to throw the Dundee at the TV and they're having that argument. And he's like so angry and he's clearly just so sad and like, you know, and then she's like, you're hardly my first and he's so angry, but he has this need to say that's what she said, because he knows I need to say it and he just shouts it at her.
也许有点问题。我只是以前对我妈妈或者说对我的父母和我哥哥他们说过这个。但这是真的。我在他的角色身上看到了很多我自己的影子，不是某些方面，更像是，我甚至无法真正解释。关于他的角色，有一些东西让我真的、真的、真的很有共鸣。我最最喜欢的时刻之一就是他忍不住大喊。这就是她说的，即使他很愤怒，比如当她准备把邓迪奖杯扔向电视时，他们正在争吵。他那么生气，显然又是那么难然后她说，你算不上我的第一个，他虽然很生气，但他有这种说“这就是她说的”的冲动，因为他知道我需要说出来，然后他就对着她大喊。
Michael also just has such a pure heart. He really does. Yes, it's he's pretty like just a person who just wants love and to be loved, but he goes about it so wonky. But I'm with you whenever he has to yell something. Every time I lose it, like so funny. I hadn't seen him yell, I declare bankruptcy until we rewatched it. Yeah. And just like his need to do that to make this announcement is like amazing. It just hurts my soul how he's like, that's how he thinks you you declare bankruptcy. You declare it out loud in a room. It's done. I've done it. I just feel that. Okay. And this is a part that I find so starting starting to watch the office at a really young age. I almost didn't understand any reference whatsoever. I just thought it was funny. And I
迈克尔也有一颗如此纯洁的心。他真的有。是的，他基本上就是一个只想要爱和被爱的人，但他用的方法太古怪了。但我支持你，每当他必须大喊大叫的时候。每次我都笑死，太搞笑了。直到我们重看之前，我都没见过他大喊“我宣布破产”。是的。而且他为了做出这个宣告而必须要那样做的举动简直太棒了。一想到他是这样认为你如何宣布破产的，我的心就隐隐作痛。你在一个房间里大声宣布它。这就完成了。我都做到了。我就是有这种感觉。好的。这是我发现的一个部分，从很小的时候开始看《办公室》。我几乎完全听不懂任何梗。我只是觉得它很好笑。而且我
thought, you know, it was, it was funny. I just liked the show in general, but a lot, most of the references, I had no idea who anybody was. No idea what movies they were referencing. So something I do blame the office for, to be honest, is, but then also I blame myself, but I blame the office is, is there's so many things that are said, especially by Michael in the office, that he says wrong on purpose, like written on purpose. Yeah. That I didn't even know the real word. So I said many words wrong because I learned them from Michael Scott. Were you a little stitious? That was a little, that one I knew. That was one that I knew. And I was very proud that I knew that one. But like insurmountable, to be honest, I thought that was a word. I thought, oh, no,
觉得，你知道，它，它很有趣。我只是总体上喜欢这部剧，但很多，大部分的梗，我不知道任何人是谁。不知道他们在致敬什么电影。所以说实话，我怪《办公室》的一点是，但我也怪我自己，不过我怪《办公室》的是，有很多事情，尤其是迈克尔在《办公室》里说的话，他是故意说错的，就像是故意那样写的。是的。以至于我甚至不知道正确的词是什么。所以我说错了很多词，因为我是从迈克尔·斯科特那里学来的。你当时有点迷信吗？那是有点，那个我知道。那个我是知道的。而且我很骄傲我知道那个。但比如不可逾越的，说实话，我以为那就是个词。我想，哦，不，
this has happened many times. I never thought about this filter of the office that on a younger person, they're learning Michael's vocabulary. Yes, learning his vocabulary, because I thought I was learning new words, which I was, they were just wrong. And then, and same when, you know, the joke when Aaron is like, my New Year's resolution was to learn a new word every day. Yeah. And it is going immensely. Yeah. I didn't get that. I was like, oh, cool. I'll start seeing that. So now, because I have said so many things wrong. Mom, do you remember off the top of your head some more ones that I just said that everyone was like, what the hell? I remember when you first heard that you two was from Ireland. Oh, you guys, you guys, you guys, you guys, you guys, you guys,
这已经发生很多次了。我从来没有想过《办公室》有这样一个过滤网，年轻人在学习迈克尔的词汇。是的，在学习他的词汇，因为我以为我在学习新单词，而我的确在学，它们只是错的。然后，同样当，你知道那个笑话，当艾琳说，我的新年决心是每天学一个新单词。是的。而且进展得非常巨大。是的。我当时没听懂。我就想，哦，酷。我开始看到了。所以现在，因为我说错了太多事情。妈妈，你脑子里还记得其他我刚才说得让每个人都觉得“到底是什么鬼”的词吗？我还记得你第一次听说U2乐队来自爱尔兰的时候。哦，你们，你们，你们，你们，你们，你们，
you guys, you guys, you guys, you guys. What? Okay. This is, this is the worst one. Sweet, sweet, Bono is, is a supporter of mine. Yeah. And I, I love him. My God. Amazing. Yeah. My God. Here's the issue, guys. What? What? Literally, in June, this last June, we were in Ireland. So very recently, we were in Ireland and I get, oh God, I'm in my hotel and I get flowers delivered to my hotel room and it has a little letter on it. And it's this really, really sweet letter and it says from Bono. And I was like, why would Bono, who's from Scranton? You thought Bono was from Scranton, Pennsylvania? I go, why would, why would he send me something in Ireland? What does he have to touch? What does this have to do with him? And it was like, welcome to like, it was something
你们，你们，你们，你们。什么？好吧。这是，这是最糟糕的一个。甜心，甜心博诺是，是我的支持者。是的。而且我，我爱他。天哪。太棒了。是的。天哪。问题是这样的，伙计们。什么？真的，在六月，就在今年六月，我们在爱尔兰。所以非常不久前，我们在爱尔兰，我接到，哦天哪，我在酒店里，我有人把花送到我的酒店房间，上面有一封短信。这是一封非常非常甜蜜的信，上面写着来自博诺。然后我就想，为什么博诺，他来自斯克兰顿？你以为博诺来自宾夕法尼亚州的斯克兰顿？我说，为什么，为什么他要在爱尔兰给我送东西？这跟他有什么关系？就像是，欢迎来到，就像是
about like, welcome to my like, hometown or something like that. But you two is from Scranton. And I was like, I kept asking everyone like, what was, what is, what is Bono doing, sending me flowers all the way across the world? From Scranton. Why would he do that? What does, what does this have to do with anything? And they were like, Billy, what are you talking about? They're Irish. And I was like, no, they're not. Have you, have you told him this story yet? No. Oh my God. But it's because when, when Michael falls in love with Holly and he's making her a mix and I blame John for this because Jim comes in and Michael goes, what's the ban from Scranton that made it big? Is that you too? And Jim goes, yes. And then he sits down and he goes, you don't
关于“欢迎来到我的家乡”之类的话。但U2乐队来自斯克兰顿。然后我就想，我一直问每个人，博诺怎么回事，为什么要大老远从世界的那头给我送花？来自斯克兰顿。他为什么要这么做？这，这和任何事有什么关系？他们就说，比利，你在说什么？他们是爱尔兰人。然后我说，不，他们不是。你把这个故事讲给他听了吗？还没有。哦，天哪。但这是因为当，当迈克尔爱上霍莉并为她制作混音带时，我怪约翰，因为吉姆走了进来，迈克尔说，斯克兰顿走红的乐队是哪个？是U2吗？吉姆说，是的。然后他坐下来，接着说，你不
love Holly. That's all there is. It's not even, there's no pause. There's no laugh. But if you've seen it 30 times, then guess what? You two is from Scranton. I thought it was like, honestly, in my head, I thought Jim thought, oh, that's a stupid question because obviously they're the band that made it big from Scranton. I thought if it was like, I thought it was like the question, like, is, you know, I don't even know, like, like, is, is so-and-so that's very obviously from some, this place, is they, are they from that place? You're like, yeah, obviously. I thought that was the vibe instead of no, not at all their whole thing. This is in June. June. I didn't know. Like, I could have been in an interview. Somebody could have asked me about you two and Bono and
爱霍莉。事情就是这样。甚至都没有。没有任何停顿。没有任何笑声。但是如果你看了30遍，那么你猜怎么着？U2乐队来自斯克兰顿。老实说，我当时在脑子里想，吉姆心想，哦，这是一个愚蠢的问题，因为显然他们是从斯克兰顿走红的乐队。我以为如果就像是，我以为这个问题就像是，你知道我甚至不知道，就像是，某某人明显来自某个地方，他们，他们是来自那个地方吗？你会想，是的，显然。我以为那是那种氛围，而不是说不，完全不是他们的整套作风。这是在六月。六月。我不知道。就像，我本来可以去参加一个采访。可能会有人问我关于U2和博诺的事，而
I could have been like, okay, well, it's really cool because here's the thing. Here's the thing. We are going to give you our phone numbers. Anytime you come up on something like, is this just text us? We're like, we're like your office aunties. Yeah, I'm gonna need to do that. How much do you watch The Office? Because I read in an interview that it's like all the time. Okay, so I play it. It's playing only on my phone. I don't watch it on anything else. It's playing on my phone at all times. When I'm doing anything, when I'm like in the shower, I have it sitting outside the shower. I can't have any silence, guys. It's like right outside the shower. It's like when I'm getting dressed, when I'm eating food, when I put on makeup, when I do my hair,
我可能会说，好吧，这真的很酷，因为事情是这样的。事情是这样的。我们要把我们的电话号码给你。每当你遇到这样的事情，比如，这是真的吗，就给我们发信息。我们就像是，我们就像是你的办公室阿姨。是的，我以后需要这么做。你看了多少遍《办公室》？因为我在一次采访中读到，简直是随时都在看。好吧，我播放它。它只在我的手机上播放。我不在其他任何东西上面看它。它一直在我的手机上播放。当我做任何事情的时候，当我，比如在洗澡时，我把它放在浴室外面。伙计们，我不能忍受任何沉默。它就在浴室外面。比如当我穿衣服的时候，当我吃东西的时候，当我化妆的时候，当我弄头发的时候，
when I, like it's like truly playing always just in my, like I'll just honestly, I'll be, I was like rearranging my closet a couple of months ago, or maybe longer ago, and I was just in my pocket. I couldn't even see it. It was just in my pocket and the audio was playing. And it's like, I listened to it like it's a podcast. Like also because I've seen it so many times, I haven't all memorized, like all the lines memorized and all the visuals memorized so I can picture it. I don't, I'm not missing it. You don't even need to look at it. I don't need to need to look at it. This makes something your mom said to me when we met, when you got here, make perfect sense. Maggie said to me, I feel like I know you guys because I hear your voices
当我，就像它真的是一直在播放，就在我的，我甚至会，几个月前我正在重新整理衣柜，或者可能更久以前，它就在我的口袋里。我甚至看不到它。它就在我的口袋里，播放着音频。这就好像，我把它当成播客来听。而且也是因为我已经看过太多遍了，我都背下来了，所有的台词都背下来了，所有的画面也都背下来了，所以我可以在脑海中想象出来。我没有，我没有错过。你甚至不需要看它。我根本不需要看它。这让我妈妈在我们见面时、当你来到这里时对我说的一句话变得完全说得通了。玛吉对我说，我觉得我认识你们，因为我听过你们的声音
all the time. And I thought, well, all the time. And you know, I don't live at home anymore, but when I lived at home, it was, I mean, it's just, it's just, you can just hear it. And I also have like weird needs. Again, I have these weird, I have like a need to like, if I'm eating, I have to have the office playing or something playing preferably the office and silence otherwise. Like nobody, if you talk to me, I'm not there. I'm not, I'm not there. And so, but when I was living at home, I'd be like going into my parents' kitchen where my parents were and being like, shh, talking about the office. And being like, don't talk to me. I'm watching the office. I'm eating my waffles. Leave me alone. Maggie, we love you. We love you guys.
一直都是。我想，好吧，一直都是。而且你知道，我不在家里住了，但以前住在家里的时候，就是，我的意思是，你就能听到。而且我还有点奇怪的需求。再说一次，我有这种奇怪的需求，比如我在吃饭时，一定要播放《办公室》或者别的什么，最好是《办公室》，否则就得保持安静。如果不这样，不管是谁，如果你跟我说话，我都不在那里。我不在，我不在。所以，当我住在家里时，我会走进我父母的厨房，我父母在那里，然后说：嘘，正播着《办公室》呢。然后说：别跟我说话。我在看《办公室》。我在吃华夫饼。别打扰我。梅姬，我们爱你。我们爱你们。
Parents are amazing. Okay. Oh, actually, Jenna, I'm curious. So you're Michael Scott, right, Billy? Which office character are you? Me, who am I most like? Yeah. So I'm most like Pam. Like there was so much of me that was Pam and so much of my early life as a struggling actress that I brought to Pam. I mean, I literally know what it feels like to sit at a reception desk and wish that I had an artistic career because I was a receptionist. So I know that longing and I know that feeling of wanting something to change but feeling like I'm in a place where nothing ever changes. So I definitely could relate to that. But I am an action person. So I'm not a wait for it to come to me person. And I feel like Pam, it was harder for her to get herself
父母太棒了。好的。哦，说实话，珍娜，我很好奇。所以你是迈克尔·斯科特，对吧，比利？你是《办公室》里的哪个角色？我，我最像谁？对。所以，我最像帕姆。就像我有很大一部分就像帕姆，而且我在早期作为一个苦苦挣扎的女演员的经历，有很多都被我带到了帕姆身上。我的意思是，我真的知道坐在前台祈求拥有一个艺术生涯是什么感觉，因为我曾是一名接待员。所以我懂那种渴望，也懂那种想要改变却又觉得身处一处、一切永远不会改变的感觉。所以我绝对能对此感同身受。但我是一个行动派。所以我不是那种坐等机会找上门的人。我觉得对帕姆来说，要让自己开始
started or take movement, you know? So I'm just much more ambitious than Pam. I always say it would not have taken me like three years to kiss the cutie in the office. Right. We're not waiting that long for that. That's happening much sooner. Would have happened at the Dundee's probably if I were in charge. Like for reals though, you know, not the drunken, not the falling onto his lips kiss. Yeah. But I also think I have a tiny bit of Ryan than me. I have a lot of... She is falling. She loves Ryan now in the three watch. I have fallen in love with Ryan on the three watch. Which version of him? There's serious different versions. Talk about so many versions of a character. Yeah, those are different. Those are like,
行动起来要难得多，你知道吗？所以我比帕姆雄心勃勃得多。我总是说，如果换作我，我才不会花三年时间去亲办公室里的那个可爱的人呢。对吧。我们可不会等那么久。那种事会发生得早得多。如果由我做主，可能在邓迪奖晚会上就发生了。我是说真的，你知道的，可不是那种喝醉了的、不是那种扑到他唇上的吻。对吧。但我也觉得自己身上有一点点瑞安的影子。我有很多……她沦陷了。她在第三遍重温时爱上了瑞安。我已经在第三遍重温时爱上了瑞安。哪个版本的他？有好几个不同的版本。谈论一个角色的那么多版本。对，那些是不一样的，它们就像
it's like he's playing different characters. I think my favorite is Ryan the Temp. So I like her early Ryan. But I guess it's just I have a lot of entrepreneurial ideas that go nowhere. Gadgets that I've invented in my mind and things that never get made and whatever. We've discussed on the podcast before that with my high school best friend, we invented something called the tan baster. It's a way to put on a sun tanning lotion without getting your hands dirty. It's called the tan baster. How do you do it? You know the thing that you wash dishes with that like fills with dish soap and then has a sponge on the end. So it's very similar, but with sun tan lotion. And then you can also get the middle of your back
就像他在扮演不同的角色。我想我最喜欢的是见习生瑞安。所以我喜欢她早期的瑞安。但我想这只是因为我有许多无疾而终的创业想法。我脑海中发明的小玩意儿，以及那些从没被制造出来的东西等等。我们之前在播客里讨论过，我和我高中最好的朋友发明了一种叫“美黑涂抹器”的东西。这是一种不用弄脏双手就能涂抹防晒乳的方法。它叫做美黑涂抹器。你是怎么用的？你知道那种洗盘子时里面装满洗洁精、顶端有个海绵的刷子吗？所以它非常相似，只不过里面装的是防晒乳。然后你还可以用它抹到后背中间
with it. You know what I'm saying? The tan baster. I know bless your heart. The tan baster. Someday I need you. I need you on HGTV. I don't know. I mean, I think I should call my friend and we should get it going again. Welcome to Celebrity Shark Tank. Today we have Jenna Fisher. She's made it. You're so passionate about it. You're so passionate man. You just described it for so long. But what do you think? What's your honest opinion? I don't know. It's not happening is it? Don't send me on Shark Tank just to be humiliated. There's lots of other inventions that do well that are stupider. Oh my god. That's your... It's not a bad idea. It's really not. I mean, I totally get it. Like, you know, you get your hands all gross when you get it. Especially at the beach and then you've
你知道我在说什么吗？美黑涂抹器。我知道，愿上帝保佑你。美黑涂抹器。总有一天我需要你。我需要你上HGTV（全美家庭电视网）。我不知道。我是说，我觉得我应该给朋友打电话，我们应该把它重新做起来。欢迎来到名人创智赢家。今天我们有珍娜·费舍尔。她成功了。你对它太有激情了。你太有激情了，老兄。你刚才描述了那么久。但你觉得呢？你有什么真诚的看法？我不知道。这不会发生，对吧？别把我送到《创智赢家》去受羞辱。有很多其他做得很好的发明其实更蠢。哦天哪。那是你的……这不是个坏主意。真的不是。我是说，我完全懂。就像，你知道的，你涂的时候手会变得很恶心。特别是去海滩的时候，然后你的
got sand on your hands. I think you need to let it go. I think you need to let it go. One day. Maybe. I'll have time. You know what? Tans are going to come back into fashion and when they do, I don't think tans are in fashion anymore. No, it's for the sun tan lotion. It means sunscreen. The sunscreen. I'm sorry. Sunscreen. All of these years you have told me about this. I thought it's like a spray tan in a tube. No, lady. It's applying sunscreen. I thought this is such an uneven tan. It looks like from a sponge. Well, that would be true if that's what it was for. Are you behind it now that you understand it? Sunscreen. I want you to go for this now. Applying sunscreen. What about your face? It doesn't work on the face. No squeegee for the face. Well, we already have those like,
手上沾满了沙子。我觉得你应该放下它。我觉得你应该放下它。总有一天。也许吧。我会抽出时间的。你知道吗？美黑又要流行起来了，当它们流行的时候，我不认为美黑现在还流行。不，这是给防晒乳用的。它是指防晒霜。防晒霜。对不起。防晒霜。这么多年来你一直跟我讲这个。我还以为这是管装的喷雾美黑。不，大姐。这是涂防晒霜。我还以为这晒出来的肤色太不均匀了。看起来像是海绵擦出来的。好吧，如果那是它的用途的话，确实如此。你现在理解了之后支持它吗？防晒霜。我希望你现在就去搞这个。涂防晒霜。你的脸怎么办？它不适用于脸部。脸不用刮板。好吧，我们已经有了那些，
you know, deodorant sticks. That's true. That we can put on our face. The problem is that the rubbing in is where you distribute it evenly and so that you actually get all the little cracks and crevices. Okay. All right. You know what? Workshop. When we're testing that in our focus groups, we're going to think about that. We're going to make sure that we get a sponge that can apply evenly. So Ryan, because of your ideas. Yes. Thank you for bringing us that. Sorry. Just had to come back. Oh my God. Ryan, because of your ideas. What about you? I think I'm a little, maybe, hmm, maybe a Phyllis Angela combo platter. Maybe a little bit. I'm a little bit Angela. And then Phyllis has a little sauce. You know, she like, hooked up with Bob Vance on the
你知道的，除臭剂棒。确实如此。我们可以涂在脸上的。问题在于，揉搓的过程就是你将它均匀分布的过程，这样你才能真正涂到每一个小裂缝和褶皱里。好吧。好吧。你知道吗？研讨会。当我们在焦点小组中测试这个时，我们会考虑到这一点的。我们会确保找到一块能均匀涂抹的海绵。所以瑞安，因为你的点子。是的。谢谢你给我们带来了这个。抱歉。只是不得不回来。哦天哪。瑞安，因为你的点子。你呢？我觉得我有一点，也许，嗯，也许是菲利丝和安吉拉的混合拼盘。也许有一点。我有一点安吉拉的特质。然后菲利丝带点辣。你知道的，她好像在
bathroom. She does. I have a little bit of that. Phyllis is a freak. A little bit. I might have a little bit of that combo in me. What do you think? I think you are way more Phyllis than Angela. There's almost no Angela in Angela, except for maybe love of animals. But I think, yeah, I think Phyllis. I think Phyllis is a strong choice. Maybe with the side of Kelly, like Chatty Kelly. Yes. Angela is very chatty. I do like to chat. Yeah. I get it. I feel that. I feel that for sure. Like I could go to your family reunion and I wouldn't have a problem. I wouldn't miss the beat. Wow. I could go to your cousin's wedding. I think that's also like you're a good hang. That's what that is also. Thanks, Billy. That's a good thing. Oh my gosh. When you can just
洗手间里和鲍勃·万斯勾搭上了。她确实有。我身上有一点那种特质。菲利丝是个怪胎。有一点。我身上可能有一点那种混合特质。你觉得呢？我觉得你比安吉拉更像菲利丝。安吉拉身上几乎没有什么安吉拉的影子，除了可能对动物的爱。但我认为，是的，我觉得是菲利丝。我觉得菲利丝是一个强烈的选择。也许再带点凯利的特质，比如健谈的凯利。是的。安吉拉很健谈。我确实喜欢聊天。是的。我懂。我能感觉到。我绝对能感觉到。就像我可以去参加你们家族聚会，而我不会有任何问题。我能跟上所有节奏。哇。我可以去参加你表弟的婚礼。我觉得这也是因为你很好相处。这就是那种感觉。谢谢，比利。那是件好事。哦天哪。当你能随时
fit right in anywhere, you're good. Oh, oh, oh, oh, I have a thing. What is it? Okay. Okay. Well, I've just got very excited about this. So how many cast members have you met from the office? So I've met Creed. Yes. I've met Rain. You know what's interesting? I've spoken on the phone with Steve and Brian. Yes, Brian. Yeah, that's right. Steve and Brian. I think that, oh, I've met, I've met, I've met Mindy and I've met PJ. Oh, well, actually, okay. So two interesting things. When I was a kid, I think I must have been, I'm four years, four and a half years younger than my brother. And he was probably 13 or 14. So I was some, some years younger than that. My brother was in Bad Teacher, which is with Cameron Diaz. And I was like a little kid.
融入任何地方，你真的很棒。哦，哦，哦，哦，我有件事要说。是什么？好的。好的。好吧，我对此感到非常兴奋。所以你见过《办公室》里的多少演员？所以我见过克里德。是的。我见过雷恩。你知道有趣的是什么吗？我和史蒂夫以及布莱恩通过电话。是的，布莱恩。对，没错。史蒂夫和布莱恩。我想，哦，我见过，我见过，我见过敏迪，我还见过PJ。哦，好吧，其实，好的。所以有两件有趣的事。当我还是个孩子的时候，我想我一定，我比我弟弟小四岁，四岁半。他可能13或14岁。所以我比那要小一些。我弟弟出演了《坏老师》，那是和卡梅隆·迪亚兹合作的。我当时就像个小孩。
And I remember going to hang out on set at one point and standing in craft services and Phyllis, yeah, was right there. And I hadn't seen the office. I was like, I must have been like, you know, I was probably like eight or nine or something. And she was standing there and I remember somebody saying like, she's in the office. And I remember thinking, the office, like, I know that show. That's really cool. I've never seen it, but that's really cool. And I remember sitting, standing right next to her, like she was right here and she was eating chips or something. And she was having a conversation with somebody. And I just remember looking up at her and being like, she's a star. And she doesn't know that. I've never, I don't think I've ever spoken to her. That was
我记得有一次去片场玩，站在演员休息服务台旁边，菲利丝，是的，她就在那儿。我当时还没看过《办公室》。我就觉得，我当时一定，你知道的，我大概八九岁左右的样子。她就站在那儿，我记得有人说，她演了《办公室》。我记得当时想，《办公室》？我认识那个节目。太酷了。我从没看过，但那真的很酷。我记得坐在，就站在她旁边，就像她就在这儿，她当时在吃薯片什么的。她当时在跟某人聊天。我只记得抬头看着她，心里想：她是个明星。而她自己却不知道。我从来没有，我觉得我从没跟她说过话。那对我来说
like a big deal for me. I talked about that for a long time after. And she has no idea that that little kid was me also. But, and then the other thing is my mom's, one of my mom's long lasting best friends is Amy Ryan. So I grew up. And so, you know, I knew her, we knew her like before she was obviously cast. And, and then she was just like one of my mom's friends. And then she, once I started being a fan of the office, it was hard for me to be around her. It was, I was because she was Holly. She was Holly right then. Yeah. And I was like, I was like, peak the office was it. It was, it was crazy. It was, it was, yeah. So she, she has been in my life for a long time. And she has a daughter who's a few years, years younger than me. And I, we would,
就像是一件大事。我在那之后的很长一段时间里都在谈论这件事。而她完全不知道那个小孩子也是我。不过，然后还有一件事是我妈妈的，我妈妈的一个多年的至交好友是艾米·瑞安。所以我是在她身边长大的。所以，你知道的，我认识她，我们认识她甚至在她显然被选角之前。然后她就成了我妈妈的朋友之一。接着，一旦我开始成为《办公室》的粉丝，我就很难和她相处了。因为她是霍莉。她当时就是霍莉。对。而我当时就像是，狂热追求《办公室》的巅峰时期。这太疯狂了。这太，这太，对。所以她，她进入我的生活已经很久了。她有一个比我小几岁的女儿，然后我，我们会
we would go to their house and like, I'd play with her daughter. And it was cool. Yeah. She's, she's great. I love her. She's, she's great. I love hearing that. Amy is amazing. You know, it's interesting because my daughter, one of my daughter's friends recently started watching the office. I have known this little girl, they're 14 now. I've known her since kindergarten, right? Best friends since kindergarten. She was over at the house the other day and she was like, looking at me like this, like, oh my God. And I was like, I turned around and I was like, what's that? What's going on? And she was like, sorry, I started watching the office. Oh my God. I was like, I have known you forever. But now I'm Angela Martin, you know, and I'm like, oh my gosh,
去他们家，我会和她的女儿一起玩。这太酷了。是的。她真的，真的很棒。我爱她。她真的很好。听到这个我太高兴了。艾米太棒了。你知道，这很有趣，因为我女儿，我女儿的一个朋友最近开始看《办公室》。我认识这个小女孩，他们现在14岁了。我从幼儿园就认识她了，对吧？从幼儿园开始就是最好的朋友。前几天她来家里，她就这样看着我，就像是，哦天哪。然后我就转过身，我说，怎么了？发生什么事了？她说，对不起，我开始看《办公室》了。哦天哪。我说，我认识你都一辈子了。但现在我是安吉拉·马丁了，你知道的，然后我就想，哦天哪，
it's so funny. You know what the other one was? I, I used to be a camp counselor and there was this girl and she was like my favorite student at the camp and her name was Piper and I loved her to pieces and her mom would come to her every day and I was like, that's Jan. That's literally Jan. And I was like, is your mom Jan? And she was like, yeah. Oh my gosh. That is crazy. That's so cool. It's Jan. And I tried not to freak her out because I'm sure she was annoyed with that a lot. But, but I think about her a lot. I hope she's doing well. Okay. I have a message for you from Creed. Okay. So Creed is my neighbor. Really? Yeah. He lives down the street from me. No way. Walking distance. Yeah. Like we, we sometimes we walk, we call it the sauce trail. We get an adult beverage
这太搞笑了。你知道另一个是什么吗？我，我曾经是一名夏令营辅导员，有个女孩，她就像是营里我最喜欢的学生，她叫派珀，我疼爱她到骨子里了。她妈妈每天都会来看她，我就想：那是简。那简直就是简。我就说：你妈妈是简吗？她就说：是的。哦天哪。这太疯狂了。太酷了。是简。我尽量不吓到她，因为我确信她对此已经感到很烦了。但是，但我经常想起她。我希望她过得很好。好的。我有个克里德带给你的口信。好的。所以克里德是我的邻居。真的吗？是的。他住在离我不远的地方。不会吧。步行就能到。是的。就像我们，有时候我们散步，我们称之为酱汁小径。我们拿一杯成年人饮料
and a red solo cup and we go for a walk. And he often comes over and brings his guitar and like jams out. He'll be like, Andrew, I have a new album. You want to hear it? I'm like, yes. It's, it's like one of the joys of my life. But he, we were texting because he, he loves animal documentaries and he was texting me recently that he wants me to come watch one. And I said, hey, I said, have you met Billie Eilish? She's coming into the studio. We're so excited. And he wrote back and he said, yes, I have. I met her brother also. She's been ghosting me for a while. And then he called me and he said, I'm kidding pumpkin. I'm kidding. And I said, I figured you were kidding. And he said, I was blown away by her voice. I got to see her in concert. She's
和一个红色塑料杯，然后去散步。他经常过来，带着他的吉他，然后即兴弹奏。他会说：安德鲁，我有一张新专辑。你想听吗？我说：好啊。这简直是我生活中的乐趣之一。但是，我们一直在发短信，因为他，他喜欢动物纪录片。他最近发短信给我，说想让我过去看一部。我说，嘿，我说，你见过比利·艾利什吗？她要来录音室了。我们好兴奋。他回短信说：见过了，我也见过她哥哥。她晾了我好一会儿了。然后他打电话给我，说：开玩笑的，南瓜。开玩笑的。我说：我就知道你在开玩笑。他说：她的嗓音把我震撼到了。我有幸去看了她的演唱会。她
amazing. I love meeting Phineas too. And will you tell her that if she ever wants to talk music or jam to come over, I'm around? Yeah. Oh, that's sweet. I met him for like a split second. He, he came to one of my shows like three and a half years ago. And I was meeting a million people and I was like, it's great. It was really cool. But you know what's, what's funny about like, I love that his, his just all of his musical talent just comes through throughout the show. And what I think is really cool is, you know, when he's singing spinning and reeling with love at the Christmas party, when everybody's doing karaoke, I love that that's in there because it's his song. But you don't know that. And you think you're, you think he's just honestly,
太棒了。我也很喜欢菲尼亚斯。你能告诉她，如果她想聊音乐或者即兴弹奏，随时过来，我就在附近吗？好的。哦，太贴切了。我见了他大概有一秒钟吧。他，他大约三年半前来看过我的其中一场演出。当时我正在见无数的人，然后我就想：太棒了。这真的很酷。但你知道什么，关于，我喜欢他的，他所有的音乐才华都在整个节目中展现出来。我觉得真正酷的是，你知道的，当他在圣诞派对上大家都在卡拉OK时，他唱着《旋转和摇晃与爱》，我喜欢这一段是因为那是他写的歌。但你并不知道。你以为你觉得他只是老实说，
because here's one more thing is that I watched that thinking this is probably a super famous song everybody knows and he's doing a karaoke to it. And I always thought the song was really cool. And I find a lot of the music that I love through, through other things and like hearing in the background of something and looking up the lyrics. And so I remember after a while being like, every time I watched that scene, I'm always like, oh, that song is really cool. I love, I love whatever song with this, what song is this? And I, I looked it up, honestly, probably like last year and I saw that it was his song. And I was like, he's a great songwriter. He will just come over and play. And I mean, I'm always amazed. I'm amazed when I love to write,
因为还有一件事是，我看着那个场景心想：这可能是一首人尽皆知的超级名曲，而他正在跟着唱卡拉OK。我一直觉得这首歌真的很酷。我通过很多别的东西发现了我爱的音乐，比如听到某事物的背景音乐然后去查歌词。所以I记得过了一段时间后，每次我看那个场景，我都总是觉得：哦，这首歌真的很酷。我喜欢，我不管什么歌，这是什么歌？然后我查了一下，老实说，大概是去年吧，我发现那是他的歌。然后我就想：他真是个出色的词曲作者。他就会直接过来弹奏。我的意思是，我总是感到惊叹。我很惊叹，虽然我喜欢写作，
but I, it's always so interesting for me when people can put music towards because I can't hear music. That's such a gift. Like maybe it's maybe some in another life, I'll get to hear music in my head like that because that is so cool. And if you can't hear it, when you see people who can, it's like your little piece of magic that you get to witness. It's like so cool. So yeah, I'm the same way. My son is a musician. He's a drummer and plays guitar. And from the time he was very little, he would be like three years old, we'd be driving somewhere. And from the backseat, he would say with this little voice, mama, you play a song with a lot of ride symbol, play a song with a lot of ride symbol. So like, wow. And I would say, and I said, I said, baby, I don't know,
但当人们能把音乐传达出来时，对我来说总是非常有趣，因为我听不懂音乐。这真是一种天赋。也许，也许在另一生中，我能在脑海里这样听到音乐，因为那太酷了。如果你听不到，当你看到能听到的人时，就像你亲眼目睹了属于你的那一小片魔法。太酷了。所以，是的，我也是这样。我儿子是个音乐家。他是个鼓手，还会弹吉他。从他很小的时候起，大概三岁左右，我们开车去某个地方。他就会从后座用稚嫩的声音说：妈妈，放一首有很多骑镲的歌，放一首有很多骑镲的歌。所以，哇。然后我会说，我说，宝贝，我不知道，
I don't know what song has a lot of ride symbol in it. And then he, I mean, I'm going to get it wrong, but then he would say like some Green Day song. And then I'd put it on and I'd be like, holy s***, there's a lot of ride symbol in this song. Wow. And so, and so it is true because I'm seeing that in my own house with this person who can like hear music in a way that I just, you know, it's so specific. It's so interesting hearing that you guys can't. Have you ever tried to write a song? No, I haven't. No, I haven't. I mean, I've written poetry and I've written, you know, I was a English, I was a creative writing major, but I don't know that I can see it. Well, this is actually a great segue into my next question, which is that you sampled part of the
我不知道哪首歌里有很多骑镲。然后他，我是说我可能会记错，但他会说某首绿日乐队的歌。然后我把它放出来，我会说：靠，这首歌里真的有很多骑镲。哇。所以，所以这是真的，因为我在我自己的家里看到了这一点，这个人能以一种我只是，你知道的，如此具体的方式听到音乐。听到你们听不到，真的太有趣了。你尝试过写歌吗？不，我没有。不，我没有。我是说，我写过诗，我写过，你知道的，我曾是个英语专业学生，我曾主修创意写作，但我不知道我能不能看到它。好吧，这其实完美过渡到了我的下一个问题，那就是你采样了
episode Threat Level Midnight. I did. For your song, My Strange Addiction. I did. How did that come about? Well, first of all, I can't believe they let me do that because that's a, I mean, that's wild to do that. Like take audio from a show like The Office that's that big and that. I mean, come on. It was crazy. It was such a pipe dream. I can't even tell you it was. It is wild that they said yes, because we are going back now through emails from NBC and standards and practices and things like that. And they were super particular. They were. Yeah. But I remember all of the people whose voices you hear, like Brian Baumgartner's on there and Ed Holmes. You hear Mindy, you hear John. I remember, I think you hear BJ, right? Yep. So I remember,
《午夜威胁级别》这一集的片段。我是这么做了。为了你的歌《我的奇怪癖好》。我确实这么做了。这事是怎么促成的？首先，我简直不敢相信他们让我这么做，因为这，我的意思是，这么做太疯狂了。就像从《办公室》这样体量巨大、如此……的节目中截取音频。我的意思是，拜托。太疯狂了。这简直是个白日梦。我甚至无法形容它有多么……他们居然同意了，这真是太疯狂了，因为我们现在正在回看来自NBC、标准与实践部门以及诸类机构的电子邮件。他们超级挑剔。他们的确很挑剔。是的。但我记得你听到的每一个声音的主人，比如布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳在里面，还有埃德·霍姆斯。你听到了敏迪的声音，听到了约翰的声音。我记得，我想你听到了BJ的声音，对吧？没错。所以，我记得，
and Steve, I remember each of those individuals had to give permission. Yes, they did. They were an enthusiastic. Yeah. So they were hesitation. Let me tell you the office text thread blew up. Oh, yeah. When that went out, like everyone was so excited. Yeah. Oh, my God. It was very. Oh, that's so cool. I mean, so the way that that happened was Finney is my brother had written this song called My Strange Addiction, just the words and like the whole song. And he was like, Billy, I wrote this song like, do you think it's cool? And he played it for me and he had this beat to it that was like so goofy. And I was like, dude, this reminds me of the song that they dance to the scarf. The scarf. Reminds me of the scarf. And he was like, what are you talking about? And
还有史蒂夫，我记得每一个这样的人都必须给予许可。是的，他们确实给许可了。他们非常热情。是的。所以他们犹豫了吗。让我告诉你，办公室的短信群聊直接炸了。哦，是的。当那首歌发布时，每个人都兴奋极了。对。哦，天哪。这太……哦，太酷了。我的意思是，所以这件事发生的过程是这样的：菲尼亚斯，我哥哥写了这首歌叫《我的奇怪癖好》，只有歌词和整首歌的旋律。然后他说：比利，我写了这首歌，你觉得酷吗？他放给我听，里面有一个超级滑稽的节拍。然后我说：老兄，这让我想起了他们跳舞时放的那首歌，那个围巾。围巾。让我想起了那条围巾。然后他说：你在说什么？然后
I played the scene and it just, just when he, when he hits that button in the jukebox and he's like, it's like, yeah. And it's so like, it's so stupid, but it's so good. I was like, this is giving me that same feeling of like dumb, but kind of groovy as shit. And so we were like, oh my God, that would be so. And also the song is, it's, it's, you know, kind of a playoff of, you know, the show My Strange Addiction. Do you guys know that show? And it's about people with these weird addictions to like weird stuff. You know, Finney has wrote the song, but it's kind of about like, you know, I've got an addiction, but it's to you. But I kind of was like, well, the office is also my addiction. And this song is kind of goofy. And it reminds me of that scene. And also,
我播放了那个场景，就在他按下点唱机按钮的那一刻，那种感觉就像是：就像，是的。这太蠢了，但又太棒了。我就觉得：这给了我一种既愚蠢但又带劲的奇妙感觉。所以我们就想：哦天哪，那会太……而且这首歌，它，它（你知道的），有点像对节目《我的奇怪癖好》的一种致敬。你们知道那个节目吗？它是关于人们对奇怪的东西有着奇怪癖好的。你知道的，菲尼亚斯写了这首歌，但它有点像是，你知道的，我有一个癖好，但对象是你。但我当时有点觉得，好吧，《办公室》也是我的癖好。这首歌有点滑稽。它让我想起了那个场景。而且，
then we were just watching the scene. And it's like, the way that like Andy's voice sounds and the way that Steve is just, it's just the whole dialogue is so good. And we were like, dude, what, and we jokingly, truly, truly, truly jokingly, like ripped the audio and just put it in the song. And it was so perfect because Andy's name is Billy. Yeah, scene. So then it's like, no, Billy, I haven't done that dance since my wife died. And we were like, oh, that'd be so crazy. My name is Billy. Yeah. Yeah. And so we like put it to the song. And there was not any reality that it would work or like be okay. But we were like, this is so funny. And we like sent it to the label and we were like, dude, like, just can you just ask somebody? We know
然后我们就在看着那个场景。就像，安迪的声音听起来的那种感觉，还有史蒂夫的表现，整个对话实在是太精彩了。我们就想：老兄，什么？然后我们开玩笑地，真的、真的、真的开玩笑地，把音频截取下来直接放进了歌里。这简直太完美了，因为安迪的名字就叫比利。是的，那个场景。所以就成了：不，比利，自从我妻子去世后我就没跳过那个舞了。然后我们就想：哦，这太疯狂了。我的名字叫比利。耶。耶。所以我们就把它加到了歌里。完全没有可能行得通或者被允许的现实。但我们当时想：这太搞笑了。于是我们把它发给了唱片公司，然后我们说：老兄，能不能，你能去问问某个人吗？我们知道
it's going to be a no, but just ask somebody. There's no way they're going to give us the rights to this at all. No way. And it was like, yeah, absolutely they're not, but we'll ask. Truly. And here we are. We did it. You did it. It's amazing. And it's really cute because, you know, the fans have that whole song memorized. And so when I do it live, they all shout all the parts. Oh my gosh. Do they do their, I love, Ed Holmes does a lot of great characters, you know, he's so funny like that. So good. And I loved Ed as Andy, Andy's version of what he thought that bartender was like, Hey, you know, yeah. It's so good. So good guys. Guys, I just love this. We're having a bad time. I know. I'm just like, I feel like I'm going to have sore cheeks
肯定会被拒绝的，但总得去问问别人。他们绝不可能把版权给我们。绝不可能。当时就是觉得，对，他们绝对不会给，但我们还是会去问。真的。然后我们就走到了这里。我们成功了。你成功了。这太棒了。而且真的很可爱，因为你知道，粉丝们把整首歌都背下来了。所以当我进行现场表演时，他们会齐声喊出所有的部分。哦天哪。他们会……我喜欢，埃德·霍姆斯塑造了很多棒极的角色，你知道的，他就是那种特别幽默的人。太棒了。我太喜欢埃德演的安迪了，安迪想象中那个酒保的样子，嘿，你知道的，对。太棒了。太棒了，伙计们。伙计们，我太喜欢这个了。我们现在过得真惨。我知道。我感觉我的脸颊都要酸了
because I know I feel the same. And I just, there's a lot of things that I love in the world. And there's a lot of things that I'm passionate about. And I try not to be like a nerd about it. And truly when I meet other people that like the office, I'm like, okay, whatever. Like I don't care. I'm like, I'm not trying to relate to people about it because it's my own personal thing. And in my head, no one else knows the office except me. It's my show. It's not, I'm not a, I'm not in a club of people. I'm not, I am very, I'm very pick me about it. I don't know if you guys know what that means, but I'm very like, no, no one's ever seen. It's like how you kind of like you joke about like your boyfriend and no, he's never dated anybody but me. Oh, right. Right. The only
因为我知道，我也有同感。而且我只是……世界上有很多我热爱的事物。也有很多我充满热情的事物。我尽量不在这方面表现得像个书呆子。但真的，当我遇到其他喜欢《办公室》的人时，我就会想，好吧，随便吧。反正我不在乎。我就觉得，我才不想跟别人扯上关系呢，因为这是我个人的事。在我的脑海里，除了我没有人知道《办公室》。这是我的剧。这不是……我不是在加入什么粉丝俱乐部。我不是……我在这方面表现得非常“快选我”。我不知道你们知不知道这是什么意思，但我就是那种，不，从来没有人看过。这就好比你开玩笑说，你的男朋友，不，他除了我从来没和任何人约会过。哦，对。对。唯一的
only reason he's ever been with, right? That's how I feel. The office is like, it was made for you, made for me. You guys shot for nine years just for me on your phone. Nobody's seen it before. But, but truly like, I don't, I don't really talk about it. Like, like, oh yeah. And my favorite show, The Office, it's truly like such a deeper thing than that, that when people are like, so I heard your favorite show is The Office. I'm like, don't say that. It's somehow just sacred. It's sacred. It's like a, it's truly like a sacred part of, of my personality and, and so much of who I am and the things that I do and say and think like, and also I just, I base a lot of my life situations on TV shows, like scenes from stuff and the amount of like,
他唯一交往过的人，对吧？我就是这种感觉。《办公室》就像是，它是为你而作的，为我而作的。你们在手机上拍了九年，就为了我一个人。以前从来没有人看过。但是，但是真的，我不会，我不会经常提起它。就像，哦，对了，我最喜欢的剧是《办公室》。这其实是一个比那更深层次的事情，所以当别人说，哦，我听说你最喜欢的剧是《办公室》时，我就想，别这么说。它在某种程度上是神圣的。它是神圣的。它真的就像是我性格中神圣的一部分，并且构成了我之所以为我、我所做的事、我所说的话以及我的想法的很大一部分。而且，我生活中的很多情境都是以电视剧为基础的，比如各种场景，还有那种……
one of my best friends, many times earlier this year, I, we'd be like in a really deep conversation about like something really serious in my life. And I'd just take a pause and she'd be like, oh my God, I know just what you're going to say. And I'll be like, well, well, but I have to, there's this one scene in The Office where like, this is happening and I just, I use it as like a, this reminds me of that one scene and, and how they feel here. And I really feel like that right now. It's, it's stupid guys. Like you really, you really have a phrase to me in a way. There are things that when they sort of get like, I don't know what the phrase is, but like kind of in your bones, you know what I mean? Like then they become sacred to you. And like, if someone asks
我最好的朋友之一，今年早些时候有好几次，我们会在讨论一些关于我生活中非常严肃的事情时进行非常深入的对话。然后我会突然停顿一下，她就会说，哦天哪，我知道你要说什么了。然后我就会说，嗯，可是我必须……《办公室》里有这样一个场景，就像是，正在发生这种事，然后我就把它当作一个……这让我想起了那个场景，以及他们在那种情况下是什么感受。我真的觉得自己现在就像那样。太蠢了，伙计们。你们真的……在某种程度上对我影响深远。有些东西，当它们变得……我不知道该怎么形容，但就像是融入了你的骨血，懂我的意思吗？然后它们就会对你变得神圣。而且，如果有人问
you about it, you're like, okay, first of all, how dare you? I know it's mine. I know. But at the same time, you're like, okay, yeah, let's talk about it. How well do you know it? Don't even come at me. I know. Well, that's the other thing is people are like, I love that. And I'm like, I referenced the out of this show. And I'll go, does anybody in this room know The Office well enough to know like specific details and people go like, yeah, for sure. And I'm like, I just know it's not true. I go, okay, so do you know in, you know, this one episode where, where Michael is like doing this and then he's doing this and then somebody comes in and, and everybody's like, no, sorry, I don't know. And, and also what's cool is my brother who's seen The Office many times. He,
你关于它的事，你就会想，好吧，首先，你怎么敢？我知道这是我的。我懂。但与此同时，你又会觉得，好吧，好吧，我们来聊聊。你对它有多了解？少拿这套来压我。我知道。好吧，还有一件事就是，人们会说，我太喜欢那个了。然后我就说，我对这部剧的台词了如指掌。然后我会问，这个房间里有人对《办公室》熟悉到了解具体细节的程度吗？然后大家就会说，哦，肯定的。然后我就想，我心里清楚这根本不是真的。我说，好吧，那你知不知道在，你知道的，有这么一集，迈克尔正在这样，然后他又那样，接着有人进来了，然后……大家就都说，哦，不好意思，我不知道。而且，还有一件很酷的事，我哥哥也看过很多遍《办公室》。他
and his girlfriend who's seen The Office kind of the way everybody has, where you've seen it. She's never really watched it all the way through. And so they've been watching it all the way through for the first time, like, as a whole since it came out for, for Phineas too. And so for him, everything's really fresh. And so he's finally like, oh, Billy, we were watching, we were watching the deposition the other day. And that one scene, what does he say? And I'm like, oh, you mean, yeah, yeah. Oh, so this and this. And also like, sometimes he'll just, he'll reference something that he just watched. And I'll immediately get the reference and be able to like recite the rest of the scene, which it's like a whole new level of your, like your sibling hood. It really is a
还有他的女朋友，她对《办公室》的了解就像大多数人那样，你只是看过而已。她从来没有真正从头到尾看过。所以他们最近正在第一次从头到尾完整地看这部剧，就把它当成一部完整的作品来看，而且连菲尼亚斯也是如此。所以对他来说，一切都非常新鲜。以至于他终于会说，哦，比利，我们昨天在看，我们在看听证会那一集。还有那个场景，他说了什么？然后我就会说，哦，你是说，对，对。哦，所以是这样这样的。而且，有时候他会随口提起他刚刚看过的某个东西。我就会立刻听懂那个梗，并且能够背出接下来的整段场景，这简直是把你们的……手足之情提升到了一个全新的高度。这真的
whole new layer. Wow, you can finally see me. Yeah. It's cool. Do you want to do a scene with us? Oh, yes. Do you want to be in a scene with us? We printed out a scene from the show. Okay. I first of all, Billy, I went to our actual shooting draft. So this is as we held it in our hands. Wow. Let's see. Oh my gosh. In 2004. This is from 2004. I was two, you guys. Oh my gosh. Look, I highlighted your parts. Jenna, you will play Pam. Okay. Oh, Billy, you're going to play Phyllis. We are going to do the first ever party planning committee scene. Oh yeah. I know this scene quite well. Season one, episode four, The Alliance. Sure is. Okay. I'm going to also read our stage direction. Party planning committee. Here we go. Interior conference room. Pam, Phyllis,
是一个全新的层面。哇，你终于看见我了。对。这太酷了。你想跟我们一起演个场景吗？哦，好呀。你想加入我们的场景吗？我们打印了剧中的一个场景。好的，首先，比利，我拿到了我们实际拍摄的剧本。所以这是我们当年拿在手里的原件。哇。看看。哦天哪。在2004年。这可是2004年的。我那时候才两岁，伙计们。哦天哪。看，我把你的部分高亮了。珍娜，你演帕姆。好的。哦，比利，你来演菲利斯。我们要表演有史以来第一个派对策划委员会的场景。哦，耶。我对这个场景非常熟悉。第一季第四集，《同盟》。确实是的。好的。我还要顺便读一下我们的舞台说明。派对策划委员会。我们开始吧。内景，会议室。帕姆、菲利斯
and Angela. Cymye Cullen, the party committee. Well, for decorations, maybe we could do, no, that's stupid. Forget it. What? Well, I was going to say we could have streamers, but that's dumb. Everybody has streamers. Never mind. No. Yeah. I think that's a good idea. What color do you guys think? Well, there's green, blue, yellow, red. How about green? I think green is kind of hoarse. You're officially in the PPC. It's so scary. We actually have for you since you are in the party planning committee now. We have a party planning committee sweatshirt for you. It's all mine. There you go. You can plan as many parties as you want. Or however, are you the committee to plan parties? Oh, gosh. The committee to plan party was a pretty good
和安吉拉。西米·卡伦，派对委员会。嗯，至于装饰，也许我们可以搞，不，这太蠢了。算了吧。什么？嗯，我本来想说我们可以挂彩带，但那太傻了。谁家都挂彩带。算了。不。对。我觉得这是个好主意。大家觉得什么颜色好？嗯，有绿色、蓝色、黄色、红色。绿色怎么样？我觉得绿色有点像马。你正式加入派对策划委员会了。太吓人了。既然你现在已经是派对策划委员会的成员了，我们其实为你准备了一件东西。我们为你准备了一件派对策划委员会的卫衣。全是我的。给你。你想策划多少派对都行。或者说，你是负责策划派对的委员会吗？哦，天哪。策划派对委员会曾经是个相当不错的
party planning. Pretty good stuff. I know. Isn't it interesting though that the first time this scene was ever written, it's called the party committee. The party committee, I know. One of my favorite lines of yours, it's your one off and you're like, Michael should have asked the party planning committee first. That's supposed to just spring things out as willy-nilly. And then you're like, the hand grabbed to your face of you crying is just, oh, it breaks my heart. Angela's whole just clearly just miserable life. Repressed. Miserable self. And when you throw that whole episode, oh my god, and the Yankee swap, just how upset you are that it's not going how you wanted it to go. You had a whole idea for how it was supposed to go. And Michael's just ruining
派对策划。相当不错的东西。我知道。不过你不觉得很有趣吗，这个场景第一次被写出来的时候，它叫派对委员会。派对委员会，我知道。我最喜欢你的台词之一，那是你的即兴独白，你说，迈克尔应该先问问派对策划委员会。本来就不该随随便便就把事情办了。然后你双手捂脸哭泣的那个样子，真是，哦，让我心碎。安吉拉那种显而易见、极其悲惨的生活。压抑的。痛苦的自我。还有当你在那一集里把所有的……哦天哪，还有白象交换礼物，你对事情没有按你预想的进行感到多么沮丧。你对事情该如何发展有着一整套的想法。而迈克尔却把一切都搞砸了
everything. And then Dwight kisses Kelly. And you're just, it's just horrible, horrible day for you. And you throw the ornaments. Which by the way, we're supposed to shatter. But they didn't. They don't shatter. I threw them. And they, in the first take, I threw it and it bounced right back. And I was like trying to stay in character. But at the same time, I'm like, why the hell is in this breaking? So then just in a pure rage, I just started screaming and stomping them. And that's what, no, you guys, the character is just, everybody is Pam, you know, I feel like that's, that's everyone's Pam, you know, and I, I also love the way that Roy is written, because it's so perfectly, he's got charm to him. And he's got like, you can see it, but also
然后德怀特亲了凯莉。而你……这简直是你悲惨透顶的一天。你把装饰品都扔了。顺便说一句，那些本来是应该砸碎的。但它们没有。它们根本砸不碎。我把它们扔出去了。结果，在第一次拍摄时，我把它扔出去，它直接弹了回来。我当时还试图保持角色状态。但与此同时，我在想，这到底为什么不碎啊？于是出于纯粹的愤怒，我开始尖叫并猛踩它们。然后……不，伙计们，这个角色就是，每个人都是帕姆，你知道的，我觉得这就是每个人的帕姆，你知道的，而且，我也很喜欢罗伊这个角色的塑造，因为它太完美了，他身上有一种魅力。而且他身上有一种……你能看出来，但同时
he's so neglectful and like emotionally abusive that it's like, you can totally see how you could get there. My dad had a saying for guys like that. He used to say, well, and he's not a bad guy, but he's not worth much. And I'm like, that was Roy. That was Roy. And just made you feel like so shitty, you know, it's just like so, oh God, it's so good. And it's just like everything about Pam is just so heartbreaking. And just like you, you really, you do it perfectly. Everything about it is perfect. Guys, I'm serious. Like this show, it just can't be beat. It just really can't. I like a lot of shows, but it just, it's just the one guys. I'm serious. We have two things we can do here. If you have any more questions for us, we've asked you all of our questions. So if you
他又那么忽视人，而且在情感上虐待人，以至于你会完全明白你是怎么陷入那种境地的。我爸爸对那种类型的男人有句俗语。他过去常说，嗯，他虽然算不上什么坏人，但也一文不值。我就觉得，那就是罗伊。那就是罗伊。而且会让你觉得自己糟糕透顶，你知道的，就感觉……哦天哪，太棒了。而且关于帕姆的一切都那么令人心碎。就像你，你真的演得太完美了。关于它的一切都是完美的。伙计们，我是认真的。就像这部剧，简直无可替代。真的无可替代。我喜欢很多剧，但这部就是无可替代的，伙计们。我是认真的。我们这里有两件事可以做。如果你对我们还有什么问题的话，我们已经问过你所有的问题了。所以如果你
have any more questions for us, please ask. Also, we did prepare an office quiz that we would take against each other. And we don't know the answers. We don't know who would win. Would you like, by the way, love to do it. We haven't seen the questions. We don't know. Cassie prepared them. We haven't gotten to season eight yet. If you ask me a question from season eight, I'm not even going to know because I haven't watched season eight since we filmed it. So that's like, okay, so we'll control the quiz then. We'll say, okay, so here's another interesting thing is that I just, every time I watch it all the way through, because again, I started from the beginning and I finish it every time. I can't believe I did that. So where are you right now? I finished it. Oh,
还有什么问题要问我们，请尽管提。另外，我们确实准备了一份《办公室》问答测试，我们要用它来互相切磋。而且我们不知道答案。我们不知道谁会赢。顺便问一句，你们想……我很乐意。我们还没看过这些题目。我们不知道。这是卡西准备的。我们还没看到第八季呢。如果你问我一个关于第八季的问题，我甚至都答不上来，因为自从我们拍完之后我就没再看过第八季。所以就像是，好吧，那我们就来掌控这个问答测试吧。我们会说，好吧，还有一件有趣的事，就是我每次从头到尾看完整部剧时——因为我是从头开始看的，而且每次都会看完整。真不敢相信我做到了。所以你现在看到哪了？我看完了。哦
you just recently finished it again. I finished it like a couple weeks ago. Okay. Every time I finish it, I take a couple weeks off and then I started over. Okay. So I'm in my weeks off period. Okay. Which means it's not right here. It's here. Billy, I'm pretty sure it's just in your DNA. I think it is. I think it is. I think. But for instance, and I think about this all the time, when Rain came over and did the office quiz with me, I was watching it, but I hadn't gotten to when Nellie is in the show. Yeah. And so she wasn't on my mind. I was just not there yet. And so he asked me a question about Nellie and also I was nervous as, do I treat sitting in my front of my face in my parents house? And I was 16. Like, I was so intimidated and nervous that when he
你最近刚又看完了。我大概几周前才看完的。好的。每次看完，我都会休息几个星期，然后重新开始。好的。所以我现在正处于休息的几星期里。好的。这意味着它不在这里，而是在这里。比利，我敢肯定这已经融入你的DNA里了。我想是的。我想是的。我认为。但比如，而且我经常想到这一点，当雷恩过来和我一起做《办公室》问答测试时，我正在看这部剧，但我还没看到奈莉出场的那集。对。所以她当时不在我的脑海里。我还没看到那儿。所以他问了我一个关于奈莉的问题，而且当时我很紧张，就像……坐在我父母房子的正前方，当时我16岁。我当时是那么的 intimidated（受惊吓）和紧张，以至于当他
asked me a question about Nellie, I just like, my brain just didn't work. And I just like, forgot about her character for two seconds. Until you said her name, I really hope there's no characters name. Nellie character question. I completely forgot. We haven't gotten there yet. Yeah. Okay. Here we go. Here we go. Office quiz with Billy Eilish. Yes. Starting hopefully from easy questions and it'll get harder. Oh my God. Cassie. Okay. How many questions are there? There's 10. Okay. Is it just, is it just anybody shouted out whoever's first? I think so. But then you said Cassie, if we shouted at the same time, we each get a point and she has tiebreakers at the end. Okay. What? I didn't know any of these roles. Okay. Here we go. Oh yeah. Sorry. That was a
问我一个关于奈莉的问题时，我的大脑直接当机了。我足足有两秒钟完全忘了她的角色。直到你说了她的名字，我真的希望没有以任何角色名字命名的奈莉角色问题。我完全忘了。我们还没看到那儿呢。对。好的。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。《办公室》问答测试，挑战比利·艾利什。耶。希望从简单的题目开始，然后会越来越难。哦天哪。卡西。好的。一共有多少道题？一共有10道。好的。是随便谁抢答都可以吗？我想是的。但你刚才说，卡西，如果我们同时喊出来，我们俩各得一分，最后由她来决定平局的胜负。好的。什么？我不知道这些规则。好的。我们开始吧。哦，耶。抱歉。那是我和卡西之间的
private conversation I had with Cassie. Okay. All right. Here we go. What body part did Michael accidentally grill because he likes his foot? Angela got it first. Okay. I didn't realize we could break in before the question was over. Yeah. It's true. I'm a rule follower. I know it's true. No, it's vicious. All right. I'm slightly competitive. Okay. Number two, besides the bride, who wore white to Phyllis's wedding? Oh, Billy. That was so good. Please. Okay. Three, what does Michael give Toby as a goodbye present? A rock. It's a brick. It's a brick. No, it's a rock. It's a rock. It's a post-it note with a rubber band around. And what does the post-it note say? Suck it. Suck it. Suck on this, guys. Suck on this. Oh my gosh. Suck it. Suck it is David Wallace's
私人对话。好的。好吧。我们开始吧。迈克尔不小心烤了身体的哪个部位，因为他喜欢把脚……安吉拉第一个答出来了。好的。我没意识到在问题结束之前我们就可以抢答。对。确实如此。我是个循规蹈矩的人。我知道确实如此。不，这太残酷了。好吧。我稍微有点好胜心。好的。第二题，除了新娘之外，谁在菲利斯的婚礼上也穿了白色？哦，比利。太厉害了。请。好吧。第三题，迈克尔送给托比什么作为告别礼物？一块石头。是一块砖头。是一块砖头。不，是一块石头。是一块石头。是一张缠着橡皮筋的便利贴。那便利贴上写的是什么？去你的。去你的。吃这个吧，伙计们。吃这个。哦天哪。去你的。大卫·华莱士的
invention. I knew suck was on it. I knew suck was on this. Okay. All right. Who are the members of the finer things club? Oscar, Pam, and Toby. I just stayed quiet on that one. You guys killed it. All right. Bonus. Who wants to join? Me, Angela. No, Andy. Andy. I think Billy. It's literally screaming. I think I just wanted to join in real life. Okay. What is Stanley's favorite day? Press okay. I feel like they all got it. Yeah. Okay. Good. Finally. All right. In second life, Dwight creates a character that is exactly like himself in real life. But he can fly. All right. What's the name of the song Jan keeps playing during dinner party? That one night. I don't know what the name is. They don't ever talk about the name.
发明。我知道里面有“去你的”。我知道这里面有“去你的”。好的。好吧。精致生活俱乐部的成员都有谁？奥斯卡、帕姆和托比。我在那一题保持了安静。你们太牛了。好的。附加题。谁想加入？我，安吉拉。不，安迪。安迪。我觉得是比利。简直是在尖叫。我觉得我只是想在现实生活中加入。好的。斯坦利最喜欢的一天是……按确认键。我觉得他们都答出来了。对。好的。很好。终于。好的。在《第二人生》里，德怀特创造了一个在现实生活中和自己一模一样的角色。但他会飞。好的。詹在晚餐派对上一直放的那首歌叫什么名字？那个夜晚。我不知道歌名是什么。他们从来没有提过歌名。
By Hunter. By Hunter. That one night. Yeah. But they never talk about the name ever. Oh, so maybe it's not called that one night. It might not be called that. It's just that's all you hear. She could contest that. That's just the song. All right. But I don't think my point on that one is going to make any impact on the final score. Okay. Okay. Who is Gabe often mistaken as? Lincoln. Abraham Lincoln. Oh, I was going to say a praying mantis. I don't want to say that. A stick bug. A stick bug. Oh, my gosh. All right. This is a fill-in-the-blank question. Oh, gosh. If Creed can't blank. Scuba. Scuba. Yeah. Good one. What's it all been for? All right. So right now the score is Billy has six. Angela has four. Jenna has two. Oh, wow.
亨特写的。那个夜晚。对。但他们从来没有提过这首歌的名字。哦，所以可能不叫《那个夜晚》。可能不叫这个名字。这就是你听到的全部。她可以反驳这一点。这只是那首歌。好吧。不过我觉得我在这一点上的得分不会对最终得分产生任何影响。好吧。好吧。吉布经常被误认为是谁？林肯。亚伯拉罕·林肯。哦，我本来想说是一只螳螂。我可不想这么说。竹节虫。竹节虫。哦，天哪。好的。这是一道填空题。哦，天哪。如果克里德不能……水肺潜水。水肺潜水。耶。答得好。这一切究竟是为了什么？好的。所以目前比分是，比利6分，安吉拉4分，珍娜2分。哦，哇。
That's so fun. I will give you a point for as many names as you can come up with this question. What? Name Angela Martin's cats. Amber. Ash. Prinkle. Bandit. Mumpy. Bandit. Garbage. Garbage. Well, garbage. I guess she does keep it. Lady Princess. Princess Lady. Princess Lady. Ash. Diane. Diane. Comstock. Oh. Comstock. Well, okay, but I don't know how many we did. We both were doing it. I said Amber. We got Sprinkles. Lumpy. Amber. Ash. Bandit. Princess Lady. Princess Lady. Diane. Mr. Ash, right? That's Mr. Ash. Garbage. Did you say Garbage? I got Garbage. So. Sprinkles, obviously. Are there more? Who are we missing? There's more. How many more?
太好玩了。只要你能在这道题里说出尽可能多的名字，我就给你加分。什么？说出安吉拉·马丁的猫的名字。琥珀。阿什。斯普林克尔斯。班迪特。伦皮。班迪特。垃圾。垃圾。好吧，垃圾。我猜她确实留下了它。莉迪公主。公主女士。公主女士。阿什。黛安。黛安。康斯托克。哦。康斯托克。好吧，但是我们不知道我们说了多少个。我们俩都在说。我说了琥珀。我们答出了斯普林克尔斯。伦皮。琥珀。阿什。班迪特。公主女士。公主女士。黛安。阿什先生，对吧？那是阿什先生。垃圾。你说了垃圾吗？我说了垃圾。所以。斯普林克尔斯，显然。还有吗？我们漏掉了谁？还有。还有多少个？
There's like 13, isn't there? Yeah, there's 14. Wait, wait, wait. Yeah, I knew there were like 13. Yeah, there's eight left. The one with the... Is there one named Jenny? No. Does she say them all when Dwight is saying that he doesn't like sleeping on? No, she only says like four. Yeah, only four. Then the other ones. Oh, there's some, there's another one. I'm thinking of what letters does it start with? Give me a letter. Wait, wait, wait. Is it the one that's humping Princess Lady that we're forgetting or did we get him? I think that's Mr. Ash. Yeah, Mr. Ash. Yeah, that's right. Mr. Ash. Give me, give me one letter. I'll say there are two that start with P. It's your cat. Oh, yes. To start with P. Oh gosh. Oh my god. I can, Peter.
大概有13个，对吧？对，有14个。等等，等等，等等。对，我知道大概有13个。对，还剩8个。那个跟……有没有一只叫珍妮的？没有。当德怀特说他不喜欢睡在上面时，她把它们都说出来了吗？没有，她只说了大约四个。对，只有四个。然后其他的。哦，还有一些，还有另一个。我在想它是以什么字母开头的？给我一个提示字母。等等，等等，等等。是我们忘的那只正在对公主女士做不雅动作的猫，还是我们已经猜到了？我觉得那是阿什先生。对，阿什先生。对，没错了。阿什先生。给我，给我一个字母。我只能说有两个是以P开头的。那是你的猫。哦，对了。以P开头。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。我能想到，彼得。
No. No. Paul. No. No. I'm just saying, I'm saying like people precious. Oh, Princess Lady. Diane. Diane. Lumpy. Uh, Mr. Ash. I can so picture it. Bandit. Mm-hmm. Penny. No. I'm just making it up. Oh, I'm trying to think of another P one. Oh, we have a hint. I have a hint. You also name your children this. What? You name your children this. Like it's a kid name? Yeah, it's like Angela Martin named her kid after. Philip. Yes. You have a cat named Philip? I didn't realize that. Oh, because you named him after your cat. That's right. Because it was named after my grandfather. But it was named after Angela's cat. Yes, because you're like the same tricky one. Oh, that's a tricky one. It's named after my cat. It's after my cat. Oh my god. That's tricky. Okay. What's our
不。不。保罗。不。不。我只是在说，我指的是像珍贵这种名字。哦，公主女士。黛安。黛安。伦皮。呃，阿什先生。我脑海里简直能浮现出它的样子。班迪特。嗯哼。佩妮。不。我只是胡编的。哦，我在想另一个以P开头的名字。哦，我们有提示。我有一个提示。你给你的孩子也起这个名字。什么？你给你的孩子起这个名字。就像是个小孩子的名字？对，就像安吉拉·马丁给她的孩子起名叫……菲利普。是的。你有一只叫菲利普的猫？我之前没意识到这一点。哦，因为你是用你的猫的名字给它命名的。没错。因为它是以我爷爷的名字命名的。但它是以安吉拉的猫命名的。对，因为你们俩……这是同一个刁钻的问题。哦，这太刁钻了。它是以我的猫命名的。它是按我的猫来的。哦，天哪。太刁钻了。好吧。我们的
score? What's our tally? Our score is, Jenna, you still only had two points. What? I said garbage. Okay, okay. I'll give you one. No. Fine. It was embarrassing. Okay, fine. You have three points. Angela, you have seven points. Woo. Billy, you have 10 points. Billy. Well, Billy, thank you so much for coming in and chatting with us. This was an absolute delight. We could talk to you all day. We do. Thank you. We just love you so much. We're so happy to have spent this time with you. Thank you. I will come back whenever you want me. Yay. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound
比分是多少？我们的总分是多少？我们的比分是，珍娜，你还是只有两分。什么？我说了垃圾的。好吧，好吧。我算你一分。不。好吧。太尴尬了。好吧，好吧。你积三分。安吉拉，你积七分。呜。比利，你积十分。比利。好吧，比利，非常感谢你来和我们聊天。这简直是一场绝佳的享受。我们能跟你聊上一整天。真的可以。谢谢你。我们太喜欢你了。很高兴能花时间和你在起。谢谢。只要你们想让我来，我随时都会回来。耶。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频
engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的 Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码 Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。